bien nous allons commencer notre matinée
et nous avons choisi comme thème de la
matinée la gouvernance hospitalière
un vrai sujet
qui a été remis à l'ordre du jour par le
Président de la République mais avant de
commencer l'audition je voulais votre
nom à tous je pense témoigner de la
solidarité de la commission par rapport
à au drame qui est endeuillé la
communauté hospitalière de Reims pour
tous ceux qui connaissent les hôpitaux
on sait qu'un hôpital c'est une grande
famille et nous avons bien sûr
des pensées émue pour la famille de
cette infirmière qui a été qui a été tué
nous imaginons la vie dévastée de ses
proches nous souhaitons aussi apprendre
rétablissement à la secrétaire médicale
mais vraiment c'est un drame qui qui a
déjà touché d'autres hôpitaux mais un
drame je pense qui dans ce contexte de
violence actuelle qui est un peu
disséminée qui a touché tous les
Français je voulais votre nom témoigner
de notre soutien au nom de la commission
des affaires sociales du Sénat je vous
remercie
donc nous connaissons tous le malaise de
la communauté hospitalière qui avait
d'ailleurs commencé avant la crise du
covid-19 si la question des moyens
financiers importants le Ségur de la
Santé a bien montré qu'elle ne suffit
pas à répondre à ce malaise les sujets
des conditions de travail et la
gouvernance étant également cruciaux le
rapport de la commission d'enquête sur
la situation de l'hôpital dont j'étais
rapporteur et que présidais Bernard
Chaumier a évidemment développé toutes
ces questions donc pour débuter cette
matinée sur la gouvernance nous recevons
madame Nadège baille et le professeur
Olivier Clarisse que nous avions déjà
reçu
à cette commission chargée par le
gouvernement d'une mission relative à la
création d'une gouvernance hospitalière
assurée par un tandem administratif et
médical
le président de la République en effet
lors de ses vœux aux professionnels de
santé évoqué au sujet de la gouvernance
hospitalière pour tout vous dire il me
semblait que justement depuis le rapport
que vous aviez fait professeur et depuis
les assouplissements qui avaient été qui
avait été apporté par le texte de la loi
ristin sur la possibilité au nom d'avoir
des pôles le sujet ne me semblait pas
forcément prioritaire mais bon ça a été
le choix du président de la République
peut-être qu'en effet il y a besoin de
clarifier les choses donc je vous invite
à nous présenter dans un propos
luminaire vos travaux quelle est la
feuille de route les travaux les
conclusions auxquelles vous parvenez
ainsi que les conditions concrètes et le
calendrier de mise en œuvre de vos
préconisations telles que vous les
envisagez et ensuite nos collègues vous
poseront toutes les questions qu'il
souhaite je vous laisse la parole qui
commence
voilà merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente
bonjour mesdames messieurs merci
beaucoup madame la Présidente de ce
temps d'échange pour le professeur
Clarisse et moi de vous présenter la
démarche que nous avons conduit pour
lequel donc le ministre de la Santé nous
a missionné par courrier donc du du mois
de février du 13 février 17 février pour
conduire en effet une concertation
visant à déterminer
une rénovation de la gouvernance
médico-administrative de la gouvernance
hospitalière
on examinant les conditions de création
d'un tandem de gouvernance de direction
et d'envisager les modalités de que
pourrait prendre ce tandem également son
articulation avec l'ensemble des parties
prenantes qui composent une gouvernance
hospitalière à savoir les coordonnateurs
généraux des soins à savoir les doyens
également dans les centres hospitaliers
universitaires mais également à
envisager le lien tout particulier avec
les instances de l'établissement et en
citant expressément le conseil de
surveillance comme un point d'attention
de de nos travaux donc le professeur
Clarisse et moi avons
défini les modalités de de concertation
qui nous ont mobilisés sur le mois de
février puis le mois de mars et on y
reviendra sur une sur une très large
concertation peut-être simplement pour
une petite présentation il se trouve que
le professeur Clarisse et moi avons eu
l'occasion et la chance de travailler
ensemble aux Hospices Civils de Lyon
lorsque j'étais directrice générale
adjointe et donc on a enfin je me
permets était content de retrouver ce
format de tandem pour conduire ces temps
de de concertation
donc la concertation et je laisserai
ensuite le professeur Clarisse peut être
exposé les scénarios que nous avons
présenté présenté auprès de des
personnes que nous avons rencontrées
nous avons rencontré 80 un peu plus de
90 personnes sur donc toute la période
de mars avril nous avons rencontré
toutes les conférences les conférences
de président de CME qu'il soit en centre
hospitalier en centre hospitalier
universitaire ou un établissement
psychiatrique nous avons rencontré
également les conférences de directeur
même configuration c'est entre
hospitalier et CHU voilà donc vous avez
rencontré nous avons rencontré les
organisations syndicales les
organisations syndicales de médecins on
conservation élargie les concerts les
syndicats de directeur également nous
avons rencontré les associations
professionnelles associations des
directeurs d'hôpital la DH les
associations représentant les
coordonnateurs des soins la fds les
directeurs de soins les coordonnées les
cadres infirmiers lancym nous avons
également rencontré
les représentants l'AMF
et région de France nous avons rencontré
France université la conférence des
doyens également puisque nous
souhaitions vraiment pouvoir traiter la
question
également des centres hospitaliers
universitaires et puis enfin nous avons
souhaité rencontrer les jeunes
professionnels puisque la gouvernance
concerne aussi nos jeunes collègues et
nous avons eu un temps d'échange
particulièrement intéressant avec les
élèves directeurs d'hôpital et le
syndicat représentatif deux syndicats
représentatifs des internes internes et
internes en médecine générale et nous
avons fait un choix de les rencontrer
ensemble pour pouvoir les entendre sur
la façon dont ils projetaient dont il se
projetait dans un fonctionnement
collégial ou pas dans dans les
établissements de santé
donc sur sur ces temps de concertation
nous avons en Miss d'entrée si vous
motorisez l'expression poser des
principes pour qui guide et qui ont
guidé nos réflexions pour examiner donc
les différents scénarios et identifier
les points qui qui en effet devaient
être pris en compte dans nos travaux
dans les principes simplement pour vous
pour vous les donner très rapidement je
veux pas être trop longue il y a des
principes d'opérationnalités
quelles sont quelle est l'efficacité du
dispositif de de décision fonctionnement
hospitalier c'est un fonctionnement
complexe que se passe-t-il quand tout va
bien en général pas forcément besoin de
de grandes choses en revanche nous
sommes bien évidemment confrontés à de
nombreuses situations complexes ou
décisions difficiles donc pouvoir
identifier comment le scénario de
gouvernance fonctionne en cas de
difficultés nous paraissait tout à fait
important deuxième point c'est également
l'adaptabilité du scénario en fonction
de la taille des établissements j'ai
évoqué la question des centres
hospitaliers universitaires mais nous et
les auditions nous l'ont montré les
comment dire les questions de se posent
pas de la même de la même façon selon
qu'on exerce en centre hospitalier en
centre hospitalier établissement support
de groupement hospitalier territoire ou
bien en hôpital de proximité
et donc nous avons également traité ces
questions là autre point c'est la
question de dans son opérationnalité de
la mise en oeuvre de scénarios la
question donc des compétences et du
Vivier disponible
quand bien même on voudrait un tandem
absolu on y reviendra avec avec donc un
médecin et un directeur de fait il y a à
peu près 800 établissements centre
hospitalier 1200 si on intègre les
hôpitaux de proximité on n'aurait pas
1200 praticiens hospitaliers médecin
mobilisable sur des fonctions direction
donc la question du Vivier et des
compétences est également un point
important voilà donc je vais m'en
arrêter là pour ma part et je vais
laisser la parole au professeur Clarisse
pour les scénarios et
merci Nadia madame la Présidente
Mesdames Messieurs donc nous avons
réalisé au total 29 entretiens qui se
sont échelonnés entre le 28 février et
le 27 mars et pour chacun des entretiens
nous avons proposé deux propos
préliminaires premièrement une petite
analyse sémantique entre du haut tandem
et binôme pour être sûr de ne pas faire
de contresens et globalement on s'est
aperçu qu'on pouvait utiliser l'un pour
l'autre à quelques nuances près qui
n'avaient pas d'intérêt autre que
philosophique ou sémantique et surtout
nous avons exposé différents scénarios
afin de faire le tour de la question
pour ne pas passer à côté d'une
hypothèse et avons proposé à nos
interlocuteurs dans développer une
sixième
en été et il n'y a pas eu de sixième et
donc les cinq scénarios sur lesquels
nous avons travaillé seraient parti sans
deux catégories une première catégorie
que l'on a appelé le tandem partiel avec
trois hypothèses celles qui la première
c'est celle qui existe actuellement
c'est à dire indirecteur général et un
président de CME et un président de CME
qui aurait une fonction renforcée
redéfinie la deuxième hypothèse c'est
que le directeur général soit un médecin
et la troisième hypothèse c'est que le
directeur général reste un directeur
d'hôpital de formation et que le médecin
soit officiellement directeur général
adjoint
pour ce qui est du tandem intégral le
tandem intégral signifie responsabilité
partagée à tous les niveaux et donc la
responsabilité du chef d'établissement
elle est personnelle sur le plan légal
et financière et sur la question
préalable de savoir si cette possibilité
existait la réponse a été oui en théorie
c'est possible en pratique c'est autre
chose et donc pour le tandem intégrale
il y a deux possibilités soit il est
constitué du directeur général et du
président de CME soit il est constitué
du directeur général et d'un médecin qui
a le titre de directeur médical et qui
est nommé voilà qu'elles étaient les
cinq hypothèses de travail avec les
quatre principes cas rappelés madame
Baye et simplement juste pour dire au
début et je relèverai là tout de suite
la parole à Madame Baye nous avons eu
des déclarations initiales assez
on va dire contestataire c'est à dire
que l'ensemble des partenaires comme
vous l'avez rappelé à l'instant madame
la Présidente disait mais qu'est-ce
qu'on va rouvrir ce dossier gouvernance
alors qu'il y a des textes qu'on n'a pas
encore appliqué les textes qu'on ne sait
pas comment ils sont appliqués et comme
c'est pas pourquoi s'ils ne sont pas
appliqués ils ne sont pas appliqués bon
après le président de la République a eu
sa volonté donc il y a une commande et
il faut répondre à cette commande
[Musique]
donc c'est vrai que sur ce point
d'entrée sur ce point d'entrée
auquel ça s'ajoute également les
difficultés que vous avez relatées du
fonctionnement hospitalier et les
priorités de permanence des soins que
les nos collègues que nos collègues
vivent et devaient devaient affronter
dans la perspective que vous saviez un
d'application de la loi reeise donc des
difficultés qui nous ont été largement
largement redéployés ceci étant
et nous avons également reçu un courrier
conjoint des conférences de la
Fédération hospitalière de France pour
nous exprimer que le tandem de fait
aujourd'hui était déjà en place avec un
binôme constitué par le directeur
d'établissements et le président de la
CME
pour autant sur le sur les formats de de
l'échange et au cours de la discussion
même
en effet les conclusions du du rapport
Clarisse et puis les différents textes
ont été ont été évidemment comme point
d'entrée il est apparu des zones comment
dire des changes en tout cas de
d'amélioration que à la fois les
conférences médicales mais aussi les
conférences de directeur en tout cas les
conférences de directeur pouvant amener
des points d'évolution pour finalement
rendre compte de de difficultés qui
restent quand même malgré tout rémanente
dans ce fonctionnement de binôme médecin
et directeur d'établissement alors je
vais peut-être relater un point qui est
que nous avons reçu en fait les deux
conférences conférences de directeur de
centre hospitalier les conférences de
président de CME de centre hospitalier
on conduit chacune une enquête auprès
auprès de leurs de leurs collègues pour
interroger précisément ce qui se comment
fonctionne aujourd'hui la gouvernance
hospitalière comment les uns et les
autres se sentent impliqués dans le
schéma de décision et quel serait les
pistes et qu'elle serait comment dire
comment serait reçu un directeur nommé
ou indirecteur élu pour porter la
politique médicale de l'établissement et
de fait dans les échanges il est apparu
tout de même des ressentis différents
et pour pour l'illustrer un peu les
conférences de présidente CME exprimant
que pour
quand même près de 40% d'entre eux ils
ne disposaient pas encore de tous les
moyens matériels dont un bureau de pour
certains d'ordinateurs enfin bref de
choses relativement qui peuvent paraître
relativement anodines mais qui quand
même pose question dans dans
l'organisation dans l'organisation de
leur mission
dans le sentiment également
d'implication dans les décisions et sur
l'attractivité de la fonction là aussi
alors c'est pas une majorité mais enfin
des présidents de CME ont exprimé le
souhait et l'attente de d'être davantage
de se sentir davantage impliqué et si on
interroge les conférences des directeurs
de centre hospitalier bien lorsque ils
sont posés la question de comment est-ce
que de leur point de vue les présidents
de CME étaient impliqués dans les prises
de décision à 94%, il répondent que tous
les présidents de CME sont impliqués
dans les prises de décision et que très
peu de décisions leur échappent de même
à 98% et forcément mais envoyer bien
qu'il y avait quelque chose de l'ordre
du ressenti qui montrait que il y avait
encore à clarifier cette relation
dans un certain nombre d'établissements
ce qu'on a pu également
identifier c'est qu'il y avait une
situation qui était différente entre les
centres hospitaliers universitaires ou
globalement
globalement il y a vraiment quelque
chose qui qui aujourd'hui plutôt bien et
les centres hospitaliers les centres
hospitaliers ou là il y a il y a des
écarts en tout cas de ressentis entre
ceux celles et ceux qui qui font la
gouvernance nous avons travaillé auprès
d'eux également sur la question des
missions et travailler le modèle donc
CLCC centre de lutte contre le cancer
puisque vous l'avez compris la question
d'un médecin nommé
après soit un processus électoral soit
un processus de choix finalement
rencontre du modèle qui aujourd'hui est
fonctionnel dans les centres
hospitaliers dans les centres de lutte
contre le concert et donc il était
important pour nous de voir si ce modèle
pouvait être transposé dans nos
établissements publics afin de de faire
possiblement une proposition au titre
des scénarios que le professeur Clarisse
vous a exposé
donc ça a été un point très important de
nos échanges et en conclusion il
apparaît que plusieurs points d'écart
assez assez structurant
ressortent premier élément la question
la question de
de comment dire la sociologie interne de
différentes entre ce que représente une
commission médicale d'établissement d'un
centre hospitalier d'un établissement
public de santé d'un centre de lutte
contre le cancer le président de la CME
en centre hospitalier ou en CHU est
nommé élue par ses pairs il n'y a pas de
lien hiérarchique entre un directeur
d'établissement et et un président de la
CME et il représente à la fois la
communauté médicale et il est
contributeur tu des prises de décision
et porte le projet médical responsable
de l'élaboration du projet médical et
donc il y a un positionnement
stratégique qui est affirmé en centre de
lutte contre le cancer et ça nous a été
confirmé par par les fédérations la
Fédération unique cancer en particulier
le directeur général médecin pilote
l'ensemble des enjeux et à une autorité
hiérarchique sur l'ensemble de la
communauté médicale il recrute les
médecins il le cas échéant procède à
leur évaluation le cas échéant rencontre
de rencontre des difficultés donc là il
y a déjà une nature
vraiment importante et le président de
la CME et positionné dans un rôle de
représentant de la communauté médicale
mais en représentant qu'il n'est pas
comment l'exprimer fortement impactant
sur sur le sur les décisions
stratégiques qui sont portées par le
directeur général des centres de lutte
contre le cancer er donc première
élément différence deuxième élément
différent ce qui est très sensible
également c'est que la finalité d'un
centre de lutte contre le cancer est
orienté sur une prise en charge d'une
pathologie et une orientation qui qui
aligne finalement qui alignent les
acteurs
nous avons dirigé des établissements ou
porter des communautés médicales un
centre hospitalier ou un centre
hospitalier universitaire c'est pas une
seule prise en charge c'est autant de
parcours qu'il faut pouvoir organiser il
faut pouvoir articuler avec des
priorités qu'il faut pouvoir décider et
très difficile de pouvoir parfois
aligner des communautés entre la prise
en charge de l'urgence la prise en
charge d'une activité programmée par
exemple ou la prise en charge la prise
en charge du cancer la prise en charge
du vieillissement bref dans un cadre de
financement que vous connaissez donc la
nécessité de faire des choix et donc
aligner une communauté médicale et
parfois complexe et nécessite qu'on
puisse avoir un président de la de
commission médicale d'établissement qui
puisse faire ces éléments de ces
éléments de synthèse
dernier point les communautés médicales
d'établissement précisément
vraiment traite de ces sujets et on le
traite pas sous un angle de
revendication individuelle ou
personnelle ou catégoriel mais bien mais
bien dans cette dans cette dimension de
dans cette dimension de de priorité de
priorité d'établissement et donc
transposer le modèle de centre de lutte
contre le cancer sur un modèle sur un
modèle de Chu ou de centre hospitalier
nous paraît
ne pas correspondre du taux ni à la
sociologie ni même d'ailleurs au besoin
stratégiques des établissements
enfin dernier point et pour ne pas le
citer si ce modèle devait être imposé il
susciterait une frange opposition des
présidents de commission médicale
d'établissement et puis également je
pense des collègues directeurs
directeurs d'établissements donc il y a
vraiment une opposition assez franche
qui s'est exprimée mais on n'a pas
souhaité nous partir de cette opposition
de principe pour vraiment en examiner
les possibilités de d'implication et et
de et de et de propositions éventuelles
dans le cas de nos échanges qui est
apparu également c'est qu'il y avait
tout de même des zones sur lequel
des besoins nouveaux apparaissent et qui
sont en cours de qui sont traités par
des établissements mais pour lequel il y
a des besoins de compétences et de temps
et de disponibilité médicale qui
aujourd'hui sont plus ou moins traitées
selon les moyens que les établissements
peuvent mettre
toute la question territoriale la
question territoriale nécessite un temps
important pour les établissements pour
les centres hospitaliers établissements
supports pour les CHU avec un lien à la
fois avec les centres hospitaliers la
communauté enfin l'ensemble des
établissements publics de santé mais
également toute la question du lien avec
la médecine de ville qui est un vrai
enjeu avec les communautés
professionnelles de territoire pour
lequel il y a un temps mobilisant très
fortement les communautés médicales
et la question de la disponibilité
médicale est un sujet la plupart des
présidents de CME de Chu consacre 90% de
leur temps à leur fonction de président
de CME pour les présidents de centre
hospitalier de CME de Ch on est plutôt
sur 50% que que 100% avec parfois des
difficultés pour remplacer le temps donc
des marges de changement
en tout cas de besoin de compétences
sont apparues et peuvent nourrir un
nouveau format de gouvernance que que
nous sur lequel nous avons travaillé je
vous laisse la parole
[Musique]
pour en finir avec les CLCC je
rajouterai juste que le plus gros
d'entre eux qui est l'Institut Gustave
Roussy emploie 3000 personnes ce qui
correspond à un petit centre hospitalier
alors que il y a des gros centres
hospitaliers et des CHU qui emploient
beaucoup plus de personnes donc
forcément le mode de direction n'est pas
le même dans la constitution du tandem
une question importante a été que
vaut-il mieux un médecin élu ou un
médecin nommé quelle est la légitimité
de l'un par rapport à l'autre et si tout
le monde s'entend pour dire que le
médecin élu par ses pères à une vraie
légitimité plutôt que quelqu'un nommé
par qui par rapport à qui quelles sont
ses relations avec le président de CME
avec le doyen donc c'est un petit peu
compliqué et n'oublions pas également la
place du coordinateur général des soins
au directeur central des soins puisque
les soignants non médicaux représentent
55% du personnel salarié de la plupart
de nos établissements au moins 55%. donc
en fait c'est plus un tandem c'est un
trio c'est un quatuor donc il faut il
faut faire attention à ce que ne pas
multiplier les intervenants arrivent à
tout ce qu'on ne voudrait pas c'est à
dire une couche supplémentaire et des
relations internes qui deviennent de
plus en plus compliquées puisqu'il y a
plus d'intervenants en contrepartie de
ça la vision de l'ARS et des directeurs
généraux d'Ars et que si un président
deme vient à dysfonctionner ce qui n'est
pas exclus ce qui a déjà existé bien
évidemment un DG DRS ne peut rien faire
contre un médecin élu alors qu'un
médecin nommé il peut faire quelque
chose donc il faut toujours mettre le
pour et le compte mais il y a énormément
de pour et très peu de contre
objectivement quel est le risque
ils sont quatre ans
4 oui mais il peut être éventuellement
réduit mais bon peu importe il peut être
et donc le risque le risque est que un
président de CME qui ne tiendrait plus
son rôle et qui serait sous la
dépendance d'un directeur médical nommé
à ce moment-là aurait une attitude de
prénom de ses mots qui ne seraient que
le représentant de la communauté
médicale et donc le risque de voir une
action plutôt de type syndical et
éventuellement une radicalisation d'une
CME ce qui n'a aucun intérêt dans le
fonctionnement de l'hôpital et donc il
nous paraît important d'insister sur
deux points premièrement une assemblée
médicale doit savoir ce qu'est le rôle
d'un président demeu et quel est le rôle
d'un président dememe c'est d'une part
évidemment le représentant de du corps
médical qu'il a élu mais également il a
un rôle de dirigeant s'il a un rôle de
dirigeant c'est-à-dire qu'il est
impliqué dans le fonctionnement de
l'hôpital donc il en connaît le mode de
fonctionnement et les impératifs et donc
de dire qu'on va remplacer un directeur
général par un médecin ne résout pas le
problème de base qui est le financement
des hôpitaux le financement de la santé
en règle générale mais le directeur il
fait avec le financement que l'État lui
donne et donc que ce soit un directeur
médecin ou autre il aura les mêmes
contraintes et donc le président de CME
doit s'impliquer dans son rôle de
dirigeant et doit être capable aussi
d'expliquer à sa communauté médicale les
impératifs et que de temps en temps il
faut savoir faire avec ce que l'on a
donc ça c'est un point important et le
deuxième point est que le directeur
général et le président de CME doivent
travailler ensemble ils peuvent avoir
des désaccords mais ils doivent gérer
ces désaccords pour le bien du patient
qui vient à l'hôpital qui est quand même
la première priorité que tout le monde
reconnaît et donc ils doivent être
capable de s'entendre et de combler lors
des Accords et de se respecter l'un par
rapport à l'autre je vous laisse parler
de responsabilités et puis dernier point
c'est la question de la compétence
un métier de directeur d'hôpital ça
s'apprend compétences incrémentale
également
et également il y a des questions de
responsabilité qui ont été réaffirmés
renforcés avec la séparation ordonnateur
comptable depuis le début de l'année
2023 donc avec un engagement extrêmement
fort pour les chefs d'établissement vous
avez suivi dans certaines régions des
collègues qui ont été poursuivis au
pénal sur des recrutements
d'intérimaires médicaux
évidemment il n'y a pas d'enrichissement
personnel évidemment ceux qui
préoccupait les collègues c'était la
permanence des soins dans leur
établissement mais cette responsabilité
c'est une responsabilité personnelle qui
a été renforcée sur
également sur sur des fêtes gestion et
donc à la fois pour des fonctionnements
de de d'organisation décision interne
pas brouiller les pistes et ne pas
processus de décision à l'hôpital c'est
déjà quelque chose de complexe donc qui
est important de garder de garder une
fine qui a un décideur et deuxième
élément la question de la décision doit
être
assortie la question de la
responsabilité on peut pas avoir
quelqu'un qui prend des décisions sans
en assumer les responsabilités ou en
tout cas sont faire porter les respons
en faisant porter les responsabilités
sur d'autres donc la question
l'articulation décision responsabilité
nous a également fortement fortement
préoccupé et là on voit bien que
évidemment
même si certains présidents de CME à 48%
dans l'enquête sont prêts à avoir des
responsabilités pour supplémentaires
pour le coup 52% ne sont pas prêts et la
question de comment ensuite
on découpe une responsabilité en
fonction en fonction de du type de
décision on voit bien qu'on rentre dans
quelque chose qui qui est extrêmement
qui est extrêmement complexe donc nous
promouvons plutôt un modèle de
d'un décideur qui demeure mais qui
travaille de façon beaucoup plus
concertée et de façon peut-être plus
lisible avec avec le avec un médecin en
l'occurrence le président de la
commission médicale d'établissement et
tout en laissant et renforçant la place
dédoyen en CHU la place des directeurs
de soins également qui nous paraissent
vraiment important et puis en traitant
la question du territoire du territoire
qui est un point important alors
peut-être simplement sur la conclusion
de de nos travaux
alors nous rendons officiellement notre
rapport début au début du mois de juin
donc dans un format qui nous a pas
encore été précisé mais qui va qui va
nous être nous être précisé qui nous
permettra de vous dire l'ensemble des
mesures que nous que nous que nous
préconisons suite aux travaux que nous
avons conduit
je peux me permettre juste de rappeler
quelques mots extrait du discours du
ministre de la santé et de la prévention
hier à saint-expo et donc il a assisté
sur trois points la place du service et
le rôle du lot ou tandem chef de service
cadre de santé
sur
l'insuffisance des progrès fait dans
l'organisation de l'hôpital malgré les
textes publiés en 2021 et sur
l'importance d'un duo entre un directeur
général et un président de CME voilà ce
qu'a dit hier est-ce que vous pouvez
relire dans les dépêches hospites médias
et APN news
c'est
sur la sémantique du haut tandems dont
je dirais l'auteur qui était un tandem
les deux pédales mais un seul conduit
donc certes mais si vous regardez le
Larousse le Littré ou d'autres quand on
parle de Tandem on renvoie du haut et
quand on parle de duo on renvoie à tant
d'elle donc voilà donc mais ça c'est
tout à fait tout à fait une analyse
particulière sur l'idée du
directeur et du président de CM1 qui
travaille ensemble heureusement je veux
dire et c'est quand même c'est quand
même c'est quand même ce qui se passe
lorsqu'on a fait la commission d'enquête
et Bernard jumier les collègues qui nous
ont accompagnés on est à la Valenciennes
qui étaient considérée comme l'hôpital
un peu
polaire l'hôpital magnétique mais on a
bien vu que en effet ça rejoint ce que
vous dites certains ça met du temps à se
mettre en place tout le monde n'a pas
voulu adhérer au système et c'est vrai
que certains médecins n'ont pas envie de
rentrer dans les fonctions
administratives un peu plus proche mais
on a vu aussi que pour d'autres
expériences de chute par exemple ou
d'hôpitaux quand il y a de bonnes
relations humaines entre le directeur et
le président de CM1 ça marche aussi
souvent ça marche pas bien il y a
d'autres problèmes intrinsèques à
l'hôpital bien évidemment le manque de
personnel les moyens financiers la
tarification Cauet toute la liste mais
quand ça ne marche pas il y a quand même
très souvent des problèmes de personnes
entre les deux et un moment il faut les
trancher ça c'est comme dans une équipe
municipale quand ça va pas faut virer
celui qui met le bazar voilà parce qu'on
laisse pas traîner des situations
laissées pourrir des situations mais je
pense que on va voir quelles sont les
conclusions de notre apport et c'est pas
du tout une critique par rapport au
travail que au fait et aux
responsabilité qui vous ont été confiés
mais
c'est vrai qu'il y a quand même des
choses actuellement actuellement qui
marche en revanche c'est vrai que la
place des services elle fait que les
décisions soient ascendantes n'ont plus
descendante comme elles et quelque chose
de majeur est-ce qu'il y a besoin d'un
grand changement législatif sur ça mais
je vais m'arrêter là je vais passer la
parole à la Milan suite Bernard jaumier
Katia pour ce poli film mouillé Jean-Sol
à la maison oui mais merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur Madame merci pour
ces propos monsieur professeur merci
pour ces propos
on vous est content on a quand même bien
compris que c'était particulièrement
compliqué à faire des propositions
excusez-moi de vous le dire comme ça
mais je quand j'ai écouté le président
de la République parler de binôme je me
suis posé la question pourquoi vouloir
changer les choses alors qu'actuellement
progressivement le directeur et le
président de CME sont en train de se
mettre en place et tout au moins dans ma
fédération puisque vous savez je préside
la FHF Paca dans ma fédération au niveau
des hôpitaux présidentielles me
directeur ça marche pas si mal que ça ça
marche même plutôt bien les difficultés
viendraient plutôt des ght et des
hôpitaux pivots et de la façon qui va
donner une personnalité morale ou pas où
j'ai acheté et savoir qui va diriger
j'ai acheté qui sera qui présidera la
CMU j'ai acheté etc donc les vrais
problèmes chez nous tout au moins
viennent plutôt des j'ai acheté que du
minhum tandem ou duo président de CME
directeur de l'hôpital la question que
je vais vous poser c'est
est-il normal qu'en réfléchissant sur le
binôme président Directeur on ne
réfléchissent pas sur le conseil
d'administration conseil de surveillance
est-il normal que l'élu locale ne joue
aucun rôle ou pratiquement plus aucun
rôle dans un conseil de surveillance
alors qu'il pourrait présider un conseil
d'administration ce qui d'ailleurs
déchargerait peut-être un petit peu au
niveau du pouvoir de décision le
directeur et le président de CME c'est
la première question la deuxième
question il y a une PPL qui est en cours
actuellement à l'Assemblée nationale qui
s'appelle la PPL valent tout dans lequel
on justement aussi des hôpitaux je
voudrais savoir ce que vous pensez de
cette PPL et il y avait vous
avez-vous eu des échos sur cette
proposition de loi et puis troisième
question
je suppose que dans vos auditions on
vous a beaucoup parlé et des relations
évidemment directeurs présidentielles
mais surtout du financement financement
des hôpitaux financement général de la
santé etc
n'aurait-il pas été plus
utile de réfléchir sur le financement
global de la santé en France et sur le
financement des hôpitaux est-il
nécessaire de continuer le tout et deux
arts peut-on réfléchir un autre type de
financement et puisque la présidente a
parlé du grave incident qui a eu lieu
hier accident incident qui a eu lieu
hier est-il normal que la psychiatrie ne
soit pas mieux financée que ce qu'elle
est actuellement
pour l'instant je m'arrête là mais
j'aimerais juste vous dire que j'ai eu
sentiment en écoutant président de la
République il ajoute pas d'avoir un avis
sur le sujet mais qu'il mettait la
charrue avant les bœufs
alors il y aura un pour préciser avant
avant de passer la parole à Bernard Jomy
on va prendre les questions de Bernard
Chaumier et vous pourrez répondre on va
faire comme le président dans la même
annonce ça va annoncer la gouvernance la
tarification on aura une matinée
consacrée aux réforme éventuelles de la
tarification puisque des choses
devraient normalement arriver dans le
PLFSS 2024
mais il est vrai que
les deux les deux moi mon sens la
réforme de la tarification est plus
était plus urgente que celle de la
gouvernance mais dans tact ce n'est pas
nous qui décidons et je comprends que
lorsqu'on passe une commande vous soyez
tenu de l'honorer Bernard Chaumier
merci madame la Présidente merci à tous
les deux pour vos
exposés évidemment on va on va attendre
votre apport avant de avant de pouvoir
se prononcer sur sur le fond mais moi
j'avais une première question qui est
que ce Clarisse vous avez déjà rendu un
rapport exactement sur le même sujet à
Olivier Véran c'était la présente la
rappeler avant avant la pandémie en 2019
et donc oui c'est un rapport sur la
gouvernance en fait le rapport a été
émis après a été rendu après la première
vague mais effectivement il a été
commandé avant voilà la pandémie et on
vous avait entendu exactement bon et
donc ma question parce que ce sujet sur
la table depuis un moment
porte sur le débouche et qu'est-ce qui
vous fait penser espérer que cette
fois-ci on arrive à l'heure des
décisions et évidemment je vous demande
pas comment ils font je sais bien que
c'est pas vous qui décidez mais quand on
accepte de faire un second rapport sur
le même sujet 4 ans plus tard on peut
pas dire simplement c'est parce que le
Président de la République le veut moi
il peut me demander ce qu'il veut je le
ferai pas donc
ce n'est pas un argument ce n'est pas un
argument non mais on est sur un sujet
sérieux on en convient tous et de ce
sujet sérieux on attend qu'il soit
traitée avec des décisions HPST a un
changement majeur dans la gouvernance
hospitalière 10 ans après on se rend
compte que la plupart d'entre nous ne
remettent pas en cause le fait qu'il
faut des directeurs que le temps des
voilà ce qui se passait avant le médecin
c'est terminé on ne veut pas y revenir à
ce temps-là mais que pour parler
trivialement le balancier est allé un
peu trop loin et qu'il faut remettre les
soignants plus aucun la gouvernance donc
ça fait assez consensus et pourtant
quand même je veux bien que ça
fonctionne mieux dans des hôpitaux comme
l'a dit Alain mais bon on y a tous les
rendez-vous législatifs qu'il y a eu
depuis
n'ont pas permis d'avancer réelle et sur
un point c'est ma deuxième question et
qui rejoint celle d'un Milo c'est la
question du conseil de surveillance
voilà l'endroit où il y a non seulement
les médecins parce que les soignants
c'est pas que les médecins il y a les
différentes communautés soignantes il y
a bonjour décrit pas la conclusion il y
a les élus les collectivités
territoriales etc et ce conseil de se
lancer à chaque fois qu'on a voulu par
des amendements croyez moi qui était pas
révolutionnaire mais dire quand même
qu'il fallait lui redonner un peu de
compétences certains veulent à nouveau
un conseil d'administration d'autres non
mais au moins discuter du fond des
compétences il y a eu un blocage
ministériel permanent d'Agnès Buzin puis
Rivier Véran et les propos que vous
rapportez de François Braun on entend
beaucoup les propos de France sont
bonnes et très souvent j'ai souscrit ce
qui décrit mais je constate comme
beaucoup que derrière on ne passe pas au
moment des décisions et vous avez cité
monsieur Clarisse le binôme ou je sais
pas quoi chef de service qui a de santé
c'est un point structurant pour le coup
de votre rapport de 2019 donc voilà on a
quand même cette interrogation qui est
que c'est très bien on va lire avec
beaucoup d'intérêt votre apport soyez-en
assuré parce qu'on connaît votre qualité
de réflexion mais on est des
parlementaires on n'est pas dans un
salon de thé nous on doit on doit voter
la loi derrière et oui ou non est-ce que
vous pensez que derrière on va avoir non
pas la PPL valve tout cher Alain mais un
test qui change juste dernier point mais
c'est presque anecdote mais la
difficulté de changer dans notre pays à
un million j'en parle avec un collègue
tout à l'heure à déposer une PPL sur un
autre sujet s'il est prestataires de
santé qui est intéressantes qui changent
les choses vraiment mais les réactions
que je reçois mais c'est quand même
incroyable le conservatisme dans notre
pays se porte ce porte très bien donc
voilà j'espère que vous avez identifié
le fait que
on va pouvoir cette fois-ci passer à la
décision et j'attends avec beaucoup
d'intérêts vos propos alors
je vais répondre déjà à une question
commune nous avons une lettre de mission
nous ne sortons pas de la lettre de
mission donc nous ne pouvons pas
travailler sur le financement nous ne
pouvons pas travailler sur l'évolution
ou pas du conseil de surveillance peu
importe nos idées à la diag et à moi sur
ces questions mais ce n'était pas la
lettre de mission et non non
c'était spécifiquement c'était pas la
gouvernance au sens large j'étais
spécifiquement le tandem
médico-administratif et donc dans
l'année de mission il est dit vous
envisagerez les différentes possibilités
pour matérialiser ce temps tandem voilà
entre donc on a répondu clairement à la
lettre de mission et nous n'avions
aucune légitimité l'un et l'autre pour
parler d'autre chose donc ça c'est le
premier point
le deuxième point mon avis personnel sur
la PPL Val tout ne vous intéresse pas en
parler troisième point plus sérieusement
pourquoi un premier rapport qui aboutit
à sept textes de loi entre 2021 et 2022
pourquoi n'est-il pas appliqué voilà
pourquoi la question la question oui oui
il y a des décrets d'application la
question est prise et donc pourquoi en
France lorsque un ministre décide voir
une autre autorité quelle qu'elle soit
et qu'il y a des textes de loi pourquoi
ce n'est pas appliqué moi je n'ai pas la
réponse je suis je déplore cela en tant
que citoyen bien évidemment alors il y a
une vraie explication la crise covid
avec les 7 vagues consécutives et
clairement les années 2020 et 2021 ont
été suffisamment occupés à résoudre un
certain nombre de problèmes majeurs de
santé avec les implications la
vaccination par la vaccination le
personnel exclut pas dessus la
réintégration etc donc que l'État ne se
soit pas donné les moyens de contrôler
ce qu'il avait dit on peut l'accepter
dans une certaine mesure et quand même
il y a une constatation et sur le
sénateur vous avez raison dans beaucoup
d'endroits ça fonctionne très bien y
compris dans des CHU je peux en citer
deux que je connais un très très bien
qui l'ont où ça fonctionne très bien et
je peux vous dire qu'à Marseille ça
fonctionne très bien également la paix
de Paris est à part mais il y a des
exemples concrets que vous connaissez
certainement que Nadia et moi
connaissons où ça ne marche pas ça ne
marche pas et ça ne marche pas comme
vous l'avez dit comme la présidente pour
des raisons humaines et donc il faut
forcer ces raisons humaines parce que
quand on accepte des responsabilités on
doit se plier à un certain nombre de
choses comme toujours les droits et les
devoirs la diète je vous laisse
complètement
oui peut-être simplement parce que vous
avez cité le territoire et je nous
l'avons identifié comme un point
spécifique
et pour nous et on espère en effet que
vous verrez même sur un sujet sur lequel
donc un rapport a été a été produit et
donc les 7 dont les décrets
d'applications de loi une ordonnance une
loi une ordonnance et des décrets
d'applications
pour autant plus fondamentalement il y a
vraiment des sujets de
paraître un peu ésotérique mais de
langage commun de culture commune
pour vivre de l'intérieur l'hôpital on
peut parler du même sujet en utilisant
des mots différents en ayant des regards
différents et donc la question de
comment on met davantage de porosité
entre des communautés professionnelles
qui sont toutes extrêmement engagées
nous sommes un médecin directeur
d'hôpital je crois qu'on peut pas du
tout en évalue pas l'engagement le
niveau d'engagement des uns et des
autres les niveaux d'engagement sont
extrêmes pour autant les regards et les
mots que nous utilisons ne sont pas
forcément les mêmes et la question dont
nous abordons les sujets ne sont pas les
mêmes donc la question de comment on met
davantage de porosité entre les
communautés professionnelles et c'est
vrai à tous niveaux c'est vrai également
au niveau du service on l'a dit le
binôme cadre médecin oui mais nous avons
aussi entendu des représentants
paramédicaux des représentants syndicaux
nous dire nous on ne veut pas revenir
aux Mandarina d'il y a quelques années
on veut pouvoir travailler dans quelque
chose qui est plus ouvert et qui
correspond finalement aux aspirations
des des professionnels médicaux et et
non médicaux et donc
c'est difficile pour nous aujourd'hui de
d'aller plus avant mais mais vraiment ce
que nous souhaitons proposer c'est
peut-être pas l'enième loi qui va encore
transformer quelque chose puisque comme
vous l'avez dit il faut appliquer les
textes qui viennent d'être qui ont été
qui ont été diffusés en publiés en 2021
et certains en 2022 donc on est vraiment
sur des décrets d'applications vraiment
de porter très récente il faut les
mettre en place il faut les suivre et il
faut les suivre ça fait partie des
recommandations sans toute surprise que
vous trouverez dans notre rapport mais
nous proposons des changements peut-être
un peu plus profond pour travailler
cette question cette question de de
langage de langage conjoint et puis nous
traitons la question spécifique du
territoire parce que la question de la
responsabilité territoriale des centres
hospitaliers ou des CHU et pas
uniquement sur une responsabilité
territoriale qui est hospitalière mais
une responsabilité territoriale qui
implique les professionnels
libéraux et de ce point de vue là nous
pensons que les communautés médicales et
les médecins et certains ont également
déployé des compétences d'animation
d'animation territoire nous pensons
qu'il y a la place pour traiter pour
traiter spécifiquement cette question là
très bien
donc
nous avons d'autres questions Cathy a
pour ce poli Philippe mouillé Jean-Sol
Katia pour sopoli oui merci madame la
Présidente tout d'abord je voulais vous
remercier évidemment pour le travail que
vous avez fait par rapport à la lettre
de mission vous l'avez dit qu'il vous a
été confié et vous êtes resté évidemment
dans le cadre de la lettre une mission
qui vous a été confiée mais pour ma part
je pense
ce n'est pas une pyramide bicéphale
parce que c'est ce qu'on nous propose
quand même
qui va résoudre le problème de la
démocratie hospitalière et je pense au
contraire qu'il faut redonner la parole
au personnel donc qu'il soit technique
paramédicaux médicaux
administratif aux élus aux élus parce
que ça manque quand même la place des
élus
un établissant pour ma part je pense les
conseils d'administration dans les
établissements
l'hôpital c'est avant tout quand même un
établissement public administratif
tournée vers les usagers et la
représentation quand même des
usagers et quasiment inexistants
la pression donc moi je pense exercer
par un nom d'âme à 2,7 pour 2024 comme
le prévoit d'ailleurs le programme de
stabilité pour l'Union européenne rend
impossible toute réforme de gouvernance
avez-vous entendu ce genre de propos
dans ces auditions
vous y avez répondu puisque vous nous
avez répondu que ce n'était pas votre
lettre de mission que de donc causer de
l'ONDA mais donc des financements c'est
ce que vous nous avez dit mais je pense
que vous l'avez quand même entendu
autour de vous
et pouvez-vous nous donner quelques
précisions sur l'échange que vous avez
pu avoir avec la MF
sur avec les départements sur le rôle
des élus sur ce que pensent les élus
finalement de la gouvernance qui nous
est
proposé et avez-vous donc des choses à
nous dire sur ces échanges que vous avez
pu avoir et puis juste une seconde
question
que pensez-vous mais vous l'avez dit au
début de propos mais de la réaction
forte
et commune des organisations syndicales
des directeurs et cadres de santé sur
les véritables enjeux de l'organisation
de la gouvernance hospitalière je vous
remercie très bien filé mouillé merci
Madame merci pour vos propos moi de
remarque une question remarque j'aurais
pas sur les interrogations portées par
tout le monde sur la pertinence de
rouvrir le chantier on l'a évoqué en
tout cas sur le terrain dans un certain
nombre d'hôpitaux on va qu'aujourd'hui
même les responsables se posent la
question de l'intérêt dans ce calendrier
de revient ce chantier et uniquement ce
chantier alors que de nouveau le grand
le l'enjeu de en matière de santé c'est
une vision globale et là de nouveau on
traite qu'une partie de la problématique
autre élément quand vous évoquez un
moment donné ça j'ai un peu réagi elles
ne sont de dans les pistes de travail de
co-direction ou de co-responsabilité
donc ça fait partie des scénarios
possibles au delà même de l'hôpital
globalement dans toutes les structures à
chaque fois qu'on en a deux personnes de
personnalité porte une correspondabilité
lorsque les individus s'entendent bien
et c'est l'enjeu tout va bien sinon
c'est devient une vraie catastrophe et
c'est peut-être même empiré parce qu'à
un moment donné il y a plus de
responsable quand il y a deux
responsables finalement il y a plus de
responsables et voilà donc si vous
n'avez personne pour prendre la décision
finale ça reste une vraie complexité
mais ça c'est dans les organisations
humaines et c'est pas simplement lié au
système de l'hôpital voilà donc je
voulais juste alerter là-dessus une
seule question vous avez abordé la
notion de compétences de métier on sait
que d'être directeur d'hôpital c'est
c'est il y a derrière une formation
spécifique c'était pas le métier et je
pense que en fonction de la taille de de
l'établissement les complexités le temps
à consacré la dimension parfois
politique territoriale ne sont pas les
mêmes et donc ma question c'est est-ce
que finalement dans vos scénarios il y a
pas deux niveaux de scénario en fonction
aussi de la taille des structures parce
que c'est pas la même chose lorsqu'on
est lorsqu'on pilote un CHU sur un grand
territoire ou à Lyon à Paris ou
lorsqu'on est sur un hôpital de
proximité voilà donc est-ce que il y a
pas de niveau de réflexion
madame monsieur merci en tout cas de
travailler sur ce rapport qui vous a été
confié
auquel je suis très sensible d'une part
que le Président de la République
s'intéresse à la gouvernance
hospitalière ça fait longtemps que les
mises en place dans nos établissements
tant par les médecins que par les
directeurs les cadres de santé et nos
personnels moi j'ai plusieurs remarques
de par mon expérience des hommes déjà
professionnel et quelques propositions
déjà je pense que sur le sur le point de
départ
qui est préconisé sur la base
d'une gouvernance par un tandem
administratif et médical je pense que
c'est une grosse erreur dans le médical
déjà dans le dans l'administratif quel
type d'administrateur envisagez-vous
parce qu'on entend quand même ici et là
que les futurs administrateurs des
futurs hôpitaux ne sortiront pas
uniquement de le HSP donc ça c'est une
première remarque sur le médical je
pense qu'il manque effectivement la
direction et la coordination des soins
si elle n'est pas intégrée moi je ne
parlerai pas de Tandem mais plutôt de
trinôme en tout cas c'est ce que je
propose parce que vous l'avez dit
Monsieur le Professeur la la la le
personnel soignant représente quand même
60% ainsi certainement plus des
effectifs dans nos établissements et je
pense que la direction des soins à toute
sa place et on voit aujourd'hui malgré
les dispositifs qui ont été mis en place
qui ne sont pas évalués sauf erreur de
ma part alors c'est bien joli préconisé
un rapport si vous voulez sur le
gouvernance sans préalablement m'avoir
évalué tous les dispositifs mis en place
parce qu'effectivement il y a des
hôpitaux ça marche très bien il y a des
pôles où ça marche très très bien ou à
une époque qui avait un médecin chef de
service un cadre de santé un cadre
administratif dans beaucoup d'hôpitaux
nous n'avions pas les moyens de mettre
en place ce cadre administratif mais
quand un cas ça marchait et ensuite donc
moi je suis assez favorable plutôt à un
trinôme quand même tandem la deuxième
question c'est vers quel type de
gouvernance orientez-vous vous
orientez-vous dans votre dans votre
rapport quel type de gouvernance
préconisez-vous quelle est la place de
la du du management de la de la
disponibilité aussi parce que c'est bien
joli de de mandater de responsabiliser
des acteurs qui soient administratifs
médicaux ou paramédicaux mais encore
faut-il qu'ils aient la disponibilité la
compétence et la formation pour assumer
cette charge de travail et vous en
conviendrez en particulier cette charge
administrative qui est chronophage dans
le contexte que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui de pénurie des personnels
dans nos hôpitaux
quelle est la place que vous allez
accorder à la logique
médico-administrative et comptable qui
qui pollue bien des déchets de de
service aujourd'hui et des directeurs
d'établissements enfin parler de
gouvernance sans moyens me semble être
un exercice particul ièrement complexe
je vous remercie
Corinne Imbert
merci madame la Présidente merci Madame
merci professeur pour vos propos
j'ai plusieurs questions s'il vous plaît
professeur je suis là
il y a pas de souci oui
oui professeur je voulais savoir si
les difficultés que vous aviez
identifié leur de votre première mission
dire qui a démarré avant le covid début
2020 et qui c'est dont vous avez
présenté le rapport après le enfin en
cours après le premier confinement
est-ce que c'est des difficultés que
vous aviez identifié ont évolué par
rapport à la mission que vous conduisez
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
une remarque une question qui c'est à la
fois une remarque une question est-ce
que regarde ce que vous avez dit ce que
vous observez en disant que parfois
quand ça ne marche pas c'est une affaire
de personnes est-ce que de retravailler
de repenser une nouvelle gouvernance ça
risque pas de déstabiliser là où ça
marche est-ce que vous avez pu évoluer
dans vos rencontres dans vos entretiens
les conséquences d'une nouvelle de
repenser une nouvelle organisation
sur la responsabilité territoriale
est-ce que vous avez évoqué madame
est-ce que vous arrivez à vous projeter
alors que dans certains départements en
tout cas c'est le cas dans mon
département Charente-Maritime nous
observons des fusions d'établissement ou
un centre hospitalier de proximité va
rejoindre le centre hospitalier
qui porte le GHT voilà est-ce que vous
arrivez à vous projeter et du coup
quelles conséquences j'entends bien le
lien ville hôpital l'implication aussi
des médecins libéraux comment tout ça va
s'articuler sur un périmètre plus
important
ensuite je reviens sur les centres
hospitaliers universitaires quelle place
accordée dans la couvertance aux doyen
aux côtés du tandem ou du trinôme comme
le propose
Jean-Sol qui sera envisagée et comment
intégrer mais peut-être que c'est pas
dans votre la démission dans les
évolutions de gouvernance la
représentation des personnels
paramédicaux et le rôle des commissions
des soins infirmiers de rééducation et
médico-technique je vous remercie
il nous reste deux collègues on va
prendre toutes les questions et ensuite
vous pourrez répondre Daniel Chassin et
victoire jasmin Daniel Chassin merci le
président de
remarque très rapide simplement je pense
que il faut absolument effectivement que
ce soit un médecin élu qu'elle a
confiance de la collectivité médicale et
pas médecin nommé lorsque
actuellement c'est le cas si vous voulez
dans la plupart des hôpitaux ça
fonctionne bien mais quand ça fonctionne
pas bien je pense que il faut là il faut
trouver une solution parce que
ça arrive je connais ce cas et donc ça
met en difficulté effectivement le
fonctionnement de l'hôpital et et là la
difficulté quelle solution peut trouver
lorsque ce binôme ne fonctionne pas bien
et deuxièmement
je pense que il faudrait que le
territoire soit mieux représenté par une
décision mais en consultation avec les
CPTs avec les élus peut-être les
parlementaires qui ne sont pas ma
connaissance pas invité au conseil de
surveillance voilà les questions que je
voulais poser
oui merci merci madame la Présidente je
voudrais également évoquer la situation
pour dans ces organisations des services
supports parce qu'il y a un pas que des
médecins
et les directeurs il y a également dans
la déclinaison de proximité de service
support et l'organisation quand même
dépendante également de ces services il
y a une grande complémentarité c'est
vrai entre un directeur d'hôpital et un
médecin qui serait par exemple
présidentielle peu importe le binôme
d'ailleurs mais je crois qu'il y a deux
logiques la logique de la continuité de
la qualité des soins et la logique de la
maîtrise de budget et là il faudrait
d'une part qu'il y ait une bonne
définition
des choix et des orientations dans la
politique même de l'établissement et
pour par rapport à la présentation la
certification parce que là ce sont aussi
des éléments à prendre en compte pour
mieux définir les différentes
orientations et décliner
dans la proximité parce qu'il y a la
toute la partie hiérarchique on voit
bien que il y a eu des pôles par exemple
il y a eu des pôles alors que avant il y
avait des chefs de service et c'était
façon très organisée avec l'épaule en
fonction des lieux et des personnes et
bien il y a certaines paroles qui ont
bien fonctionné et d'autres pas
forcément donc en fait il faut évaluer
l'existant bon je vous l'avais sans
doute fait avec le travail que vous
évoquez mais je crois qu'il faut
également à chaque niveau définir ce
qu'on veut parce que ce qu'on veut pour
la direction même c'est pas forcément la
même chose dans la proximité avec les
cadres et les chefs de service qui
travaillent avec les personnes mais
aussi en fonction des services par
exemple dans dans les services de soins
et dans les laboratoires ou autres
services support ce n'est pas la même
chose donc il faudrait vraiment définir
et la question du management et à
prendre en compte également parce que
il y a des personnes qui sont
compétentes qui ont une bonne expérience
mais qui ne savent pas communiquer et
quelquefois il y a des freins au
développement de l'organisation à
l'amélioration de la qualité des
relations et des soins également tout
simplement parce qu'il y a des personnes
qui n'ont pas cette notion de management
et qui dès lors que qu'elles ont des
responsabilités et bien se focalisent
sur certains aspects et
non pas à la façon de communiquer qui
permettrait d'améliorer les relations et
de fluidifier la qualité voilà merci
très bien alors qui commence professeur
oui d'autant plus je suis désolé mais
j'ai un tout petit impératif je dois
prendre un train donc il faudra que je
parte impérativement vers 10h10 10h15 je
suis désolé donc mais je vais
je vais répondre de très brièvement
alors nous n'avons pas oublié ni les
représentants des usagers ni les
coordinateurs de soins ni les doyens et
donc nous en avons tenu compte puisque
nous avons rencontré comme jamais dit
Madame Baye l'Association des Directeurs
de soins et l'association des cadres de
santé et j'ai eu l'occasion d'aller à
plusieurs reprises à des réunions
organisées par l'association des cadres
de santé et nous sommes tout à fait en
phase donc le rôle du directeur de soins
est bien pris en compte le rôle
spécifique du Doyen dans les sièges et
bien pris en compte il y a des
paragraphes entiers dans le rapport
consacré à cela donc ça nous n'avons pas
oublié après comme toujours il y a des
variations d'hôpital mais il y a plein
d'endroits où les usagers ont une vraie
place et je travaille dans une
institution où la place des usagers est
particulièrement bien représentée que ce
soit dans le fonctionnement même de
l'hôpital puisqu'il arrive à
représentant des usagers qui est un
salarié de l'hôpital pour spécifiquement
travailler sur le patient traceur etc et
que le vice-président du conseil de
surveillance est un représentant des
usagers donc ça c'est le premier point
le deuxième point qui est important
c'est l'adaptation des décisions à la
taille des établissements nous en avons
tenu compte et c'était
typiquement inscrit dans la lettre de
mission donc il y a une réponse par
rapport à cela le troisième point et ça
le ministre de la Santé l'avait dit en
ouverture de la journée organisée par
l'Association des Directeurs des
hôpitaux il a dit très clairement il y a
des endroits où ça marche on ne va pas
revenir dessus ni le déstabiliser ce que
je souhaite changer a-t-il dit c'est les
endroits où ça ne marche pas et donc on
est bien d'accord que l'objectif de ce
travail n'est pas de déstabiliser ce qui
fonctionne bien qui est quand même la
majorité des cas mais il y a trop
d'endroits où ça dysfonctionne les
conflits de personnes ils existeront
toujours c'est la nature humaine c'est
comme ça et nous avons réfléchi
notamment aux dysfonctionnements du
tandem enfin dernier point de deuxième
point encore nous avons travaillé
spécifiquement sur les relations entre
la CME et l'action la comité des soins
infirmiers de rééducation et
médico-technique donc cet aspect n'a pas
été oublié et quant à la disponibilité
des managers c'est aussi un point
important je vous laisse finir
oui merci donc peut-être vous m'avez
vous nous m'avez interrogé sur sur les
retours de l'AMF que nous avons en effet
de régions de France que nous avons en
effet auditionné en fait le on n'a pas
eu de proposition formelle de leur part
si ce n'est la question du conseil
d'administration versus conseils de
surveillance qui est le point le point
qui revient
dans dans les éléments de proposition
comme on vous l'a dit le l'objectif
n'était pas de remodifier la composition
du conseil de surveillance dans dans nos
échanges en revanche le positionnement
du conseil de surveillance dans les
projets de gouvernance nous l'avons
intégré nous avons fait une proposition
également pour pour travailler pour
travailler cette articulation tout
spécifique
vous avez été nombreux à le dire il y a
un sujet
de représentation et d'associations de
finalement de toute la ligne
fonctionnelle d'un établissement qui
n'est pas que médical qui est
administrative technique etc et donc
derrière les sujets de gouvernance la
question qui se pose est en fait comment
on anime une communauté comment on
comment manager une équipe donc
plusieurs points plusieurs points
notre mission nous était sur le tandem
mais le il y a également une lettre de
mission une mission qui était confiée à
la nappe sur la question du service sur
la question également des délégations et
donc là encore la question de nous avons
également dans nos propositions
repérées les sujets de quel niveau de
délégation opéré pour en effet
avoir une des circuits de décision plus
courts dans et en tout cas plus adapté
aux situations spécifiques spécifiques
des unités des équipes
on va être très modeste en un mois nous
n'avons pas fait un traité sur la
gouvernance et le management hospitalier
vous allez peut-être déçu mais on n'a
pas fait une anamnèse de l'ensemble des
schémas de fonctionnement managériaux
mais la question de la formation la
question de la communication c'est
déterminant et en revanche là pour le
coup vous le verrez aussi nous avons des
propositions enfin nous pour dévoiler
nous proposons vraiment des dispositifs
spécifiques d'accompagnement parce que
parce que de fait de fait ça ne
s'improvise pas et de fait bien sûr il y
a des questions de personnes mais il y a
aussi beaucoup de maladresses on le sait
et donc la question de de pouvoir
traiter traiter ces sujets là est un
point important monsieur vous m'aviez
vous nous avez interpellé sur sur le
fonctionnement
un chef de chef vous l'avez compris dans
nos propos on bien évidemment nous
partageons et nous avons également
alors là encore une fois un mois on n'a
pas fait le revu de littérature complète
sur le fonctionnement dans d'autres
complets de de tous les États mais on a
regardé ce qui se passait dans les pays
anglo-saxons en Europe globalement de
toute façon il y a toujours un quelqu'un
qui décide pour autant il y a des
fonctionnements peut-être plus pluriel
que ceux que nous avons dans nos
établissements et la question en effet
de comment au sein des directoires
le doyen le
président de la commission le directeur
des soins le directeur et et le
président de la CME fonctionne collabore
ça c'est un sujet qui mérite d'être
probablement davantage clarifié que ce
que ce n'est aujourd'hui l'évaluation
complète de des dispositions de
2021-2022 on l'a pas conduite
complètement en revanche on l'a vraiment
traité dans le cas de nos auditions
peut-être simplement se dire nous ce
qu'on souhaite pas c'est empiler de
nouveaux textes à des textes qui
viennent qui viennent tout juste d'être
publiés pour avoir dirigé plusieurs
types d'établissements et vous nous avez
posé également cette question évidemment
on dirige pas tout à fait un CHU je
dirigé le CHU Dijon j'étais déjà aux
hospices de Lyon avant j'étais
directrice du Centre Hospitalier de
Montélimar et puis il se trouve que dans
ma carrière j'ai assuré une très à peu
près 13 je crois intérim de de direction
dans différents établissements
médico-sociaux donc je vois à peu près
comment se compose et comment et quels
sont les communautés également et les
disponibilités que les uns et les autres
peuvent consacrer la culture également
administrative qu'il faut prendre en
compte dans dans une responsabilité
direction d'établissement comme vous
l'avez dit qu'il doit concilier à la
fois des logiques de réponses aux
besoins de santé des logiques de
réponses et de conditions de travail et
puis des sujets de respect des finances
publiques puisque dans les
d'investissement qui sont les nôtres ça
fait aussi partie de de ce qu'on attend
d'un directeur d'établissement et donc
dans les propositions que nous faisons
nous tenons compte
nos tenons de la taille des
établissements en particulier la
question des hôpitaux de proximité pour
nous ne doit pas être on peut le dire
aujourd'hui on en fait pas un sujet en
revanche on pense que entre centre
hospitalier établissement support et CHU
la question de la responsabilité
territoriale se pose dans les mêmes
termes et donc là il y a des il y a
probablement des questions et des
propositions conjointes que nous en tout
cas que que nous avons que nous avons
formulé mais peut-être voilà en synthèse
notre proposition n'est pas d'ajouter
des instances à de nouvelles instances
parce que sinon c'est beaucoup de temps
et pour le coup alors ça c'est de
l'administratif c'est vécu comme de
l'administratif par les professionnels
mais c'est tout simplement de la
coordination entre des cercles de
décision des cercles de concertation qui
sont déjà nombreux dans les
établissements de santé donc l'objectif
c'est déjà de peut-être de faire
fonctionner les instances qui existent
en particulier le Directoire qui est
quand même une une
instance qui a été profondément remaniée
en 2021 avec une renfort de la présence
médicale un renfort des personnels
paramédicaux et également la possibilité
d'impliquer les usagers les
usagers davantage donc nous pensons que
les dispositions existent en revanche il
faut il faut pouvoir les animer et mais
éviter d'empiler encore de nouvelles
dispositions qui vont alourdir qui vont
alourdir le système
merci merci à tous les deux bon retour
et nous attendons le rapport avec
impatience voilà
nous enchaînons avec les présidents
ce sont pas là on aura leur
très bien on s'installe on s'installe
bonjour Colette
très bien
c'est en visio ça aussi
donc mes chers collègues nous
poursuivons nos travaux de cette matinée
sur la gouvernance hospitalière
et nous avons donc organiser cette table
ronde qui réunit les représentants des
structures dirigeantes des
établissements nous recevons ainsi
Monsieur Philippe président de la
Conférence des directeurs généraux de
centre hospitalier universitaire ce
Francis Saint-Hubert président de la
Conférence nationale des directeurs de
centre hospitalier professeur Rémy
Salomon président de la Conférence
nationale des présidents de commission
médicale d'établissements de centre
hospitaliers et le docteur David Pinet
vice-président de la Conférence des
présidents de la commission médicale
d'établissement de centre hospitalier
nous avons accueilli tout à l'heure
professeur Clarisse et Madame bye qui
nous ont présenté à la fois la feuille
de route qu'ils avaient et maintenant
suite aux propos du président de la
République lors des vœux aux
professionnels de santé un peu la
démarche réalisée les différents
scénarii éventuellement envisagé ils
nous ont dit qu'ils sort donnerait le
rapport début juin
donc je leur ai dit en propos liminaire
que pour ma part c'était un avis tout à
fait personnel mais bon c'était une
commande et on comprenait qu'il devait
répondre à la commande qu'il aurait été
faite mais dans la situation était à
l'hôpital repartir à nouveau sur quelque
chose qui bouleversera la gouvernance
même s'il y a des améliorations à faire
n'était peut-être pas l'urgence que la
Commission voyait et qui avait d'autres
points abordés mais néanmoins
ils répondent à cette demande et nous
les avons entendu et nous attendons avec
intérêt bien évidemment le rapport qui
sortira mais nous souhaitons aussi vous
entendre vos cadeaux aux manettes des
établissements de taille différente mais
aux manettes pour voir comment vous avez
vu perçu cette mission et surtout les
points d'amélioration qui pourraient
être pris en compte sachant que la
dernière loi qui était la loi riste elle
est récente on en a pas encore tellement
vu les les effets l'application voilà
alors qui commence professeur Misano
d'accord bon merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames Messieurs les sénatrice
sénateurs
merci de nous recevoir aujourd'hui pour
parler de ce sujet bien que je partage
le point que vous venez de de
d'évoquer à savoir que ce sujet de la
gouvernance n'est pas le plus important
aujourd'hui il y a bien d'autres sujets
dans le domaine de l'hôpital et de la
santé en général qui qui nous occupent
et celui là je dis pas qu'il est pas
important mais dans la hiérarchie
des sujets pas celui qui vient sur sur
le en premier ceci étant dit il y a une
commande comme vous l'avez dit le
président de la République le 6 janvier
dans ses vœux a annoncé qui voulait
qu'on réfléchisse tandem médicaux
administratif puisque c'était le terme
je crois qu'il a employé à ce moment là
comme vous l'avez rappelé il y a déjà
pas mal de choses qui ont été faites
écrites même légiférer et la Loire iste
à dans ce sens quand même écrit un
certain nombre de choses il y avait même
des choses qui étaient dans le Code de
Santé publique qui
peut-être fera bon de rappeler aussi qui
n'est pas forcément toujours toujours
appliquée donc nous on pense de manière
générale je pense que je partage avec
avec ce qu'on a eu comme vous pouvez
l'imaginer avec mes partenaires de la
conférence des ch et avec les la
conférence de directeurs
de Chu de ch mais aussi avec les doyens
on va dire un mot conférence des doyens
on a évoqué ces sujets
pas mal de reprises ces dernières
semaines et on est quand même assez
d'accord sur le fait qu'aujourd'hui ça
marche pas si mal quand même le
gouvernance le tandem
médico-administratif et ça marcherait
peut-être encore mieux si effectivement
ce qui a été mis dans la loi Rist était
comme vous l'avez dit il est peut-être
encore un tout petit peu tôt mais je
pense que David Pinet vous vous évoquera
une enquête qui a été faite de récemment
et qui justement souligne que sur le
terrain les attentes sont encore voilà
les gens attendent encore les
l'application de de la loire-est pour ce
qui concerne le moins la gouvernance il
y a deux aspects dans la gouvernance je
pense qu'on peut aborder je crois que
vous aviez dans les questions que vous
nous avez envoyées il y a deux aspects
il y a comment fonctionne comment ça
fonctionne à la tête donc là c'est le
tandem mais d'icône administratif et
puis comment ça fonctionne sur le
terrain en vrai c'est les services et ça
c'est voilà j'enfonce une porte ouverte
depuis depuis la loi HPST les pôles
on entend régulièrement les les les les
soignants les médecins mais aussi des
paramédicaux ceux qui font ceux qui sont
dans les services se plaindre un peu de
de la perte de sens au niveau du service
des difficultés
voilà donc je pense que c'est ça je vais
peut-être il faut qu'on aborde les deux
sujets qui me paraissent donc on peut je
peux le faire rapidement dans mon propos
liminaire puis je pense qu'on reviendra
dessus dans la discussion mais ces deux
choses qui sont qui sont importantes
peut-être la deuxième encore plus que
que la première donc sur le voilà sur le
tandem nous on a
plusieurs scénaristes je pense que
Monsieur
Clarisse monsieur Clarisse et Madame
vierge et Madame et Madame Baye ont dû
vous en parler les quatre scénaris qui
étaient effectivement proposé par le par
le le président de la République nous on
pense qu'il faut pas changer il y a il y
a un représentant élu de la communauté
médicale dans le tandem et je pense
qu'il faut garder un représentant élu ça
ça a des avantages ça pas forcément
toujours évident pour un représentant
élu de faire
de faire le lien entre
les l'expression de la communauté
médicale et les les je dirais le cadre
de de la direction qui nécessite voilà
il y a certaines contraintes notamment
des contraintes budgétaires mais pas que
et donc je crois que le fait d'avoir un
représentant élu de la communauté
médicale est à nos yeux quelque chose
qui est un avantage car ça permet de
faire le lien c'est-à-dire de à la fois
d'être et c'est son rôle
d'exprimer la parole des médecins à la
direction mais en même temps de faire
comprendre à la communauté médicale qui
a des contrats et qu'il faut essayer de
jouer avec les deux et donc c'est cette
espèce de de lien permanent qui est pas
si simple à faire mais qui est à nos
yeux importants d'autant plus important
qu'on est dans une période où il y a les
lignes doivent bouger il y a des choses
qui doivent évoluer et on sait que les
médecins sont pas hospitaliers peut-être
encore plus je prends Hospital à
l'universitaire sont pas toujours
forcément
comment dire pour peuvent avoir
certaines réticences au changement et
donc je pense qu'il est important que
que le pcme qui est qui joue ce rôle à
la fois de d'expression la parole
médicale mais aussi de d'accord
d'alliance avec la direction
je pense que cette position est assez
très
utile je pense que là on est vraiment
dans la subtilité je et je crains que de
la part je me permets de le dire un peu
directement de aux yeux de certains et
peut-être du président de la République
l'idée de se dire si on a un médecin
directeur finalement ça marchera mieux
parce qu'il connaît mieux les choses et
cette manière de médicaliser la
gouvernance voilà on pourrait mettre
aussi dire bon ben on a un médecin
ministre de la Santé on peut avoir un
agriculteur ministre de l'Agriculture
etc je suis pas sûr que ce soit la
meilleure manière de faire pour autant
que des médecins accèdent au poste de
direction pourquoi pas ça se fait dans
plein de pays dans beaucoup d'autres
pays ce sont plus des médecins qui sont
des peuples de direction que des
administratifs moi je pense que c'est à
partir du moment où un médecin devient
directeur bah il apprend un nouveau
métier il devient directeur il apprend
ce métier là et pourquoi pas et pourquoi
pas et je pense que là pour le coup on
partage avec les directeurs cette idée
que il faut il faut accepter l'idée que
certains nombre de médecins mais
aujourd'hui c'est pas du tout dans notre
culture et quand bien même on déciderait
aujourd'hui le but en blanc de dire bon
bah voilà à partir de maintenant ce sont
des médecins qui vont être au poste de
direction on aurait pas grand monde pour
pour remplir ce poste là bon donc nous
on pense que le temps de tel qu'il est
bien mais avec je vais mettre juste un
petit bémol c'est là que ça fait sujet
partie des discussions et parfois des
des petites frictions qui peut y avoir
avec les directeurs mais je pense que
c'est après les mots ont leur importance
aussi
nous moi ce que je vois qui est qui
aujourd'hui manque au président de CME
c'est le plus c'est l'information on
peut parler aussi de la formation on
vient de parler de la formation je pense
que la vie Pinard parlera peut-être de
la formation mais l'information si on
veut participer aux décisions
il faut qu'on soit informé si on n'est
pas bien informé on participe pas bien
et je pense que alors c'est très
variable d'un endroit à l'autre et c'est
très dépendant finalement de la bonne
volonté de la direction de partager
l'information mais je constate qu'à
certains endroits et quand même et moi
je suis président de d'un CHU un peu
particulier
et donc je mets toujours un tout petit
peu de réserve après sur sur
l'expression de de ce que je vis mais je
suis très attentif à être à l'écoute des
autres présidents de CME des autres CHU
et je constate que ce que je dis est
quand même très partagé l'information on
l'a pas toujours où on l'a un peu au
dernier moment où on l'a de manière
parcellaire on a un diaporama la veille
du directoire plutôt qu'une note qui
soit bien bien élaborée qui nous
permettent suffisamment à l'avance de
réfléchir d'instruire le dossier etc
donc je pense que cette partage
d'informations il est assez crucial et
c'est pour cette raison là
ça existe j’évoquais le Code de Santé
publique c'est dans le Code de Santé
Publique ça le pcme doit on doit fournir
au pcme toute l'information nécessaire à
tous les champs de compétences sauf que
en pratique c'est voilà ça dépend des
gens après et donc c'est pour cette
raison-là que nous avions évoqué et
c'est le sujet qui peut effectivement
sur lequel on peut ne pas être d'accord
avec les directeurs l'idée que le PCM
puisse participer à la nomination des
directions fonctionnelles qui sont dans
le dans son champ de d'intérêt
c'est-à-dire les affaires médicales la
stratégie médicale la recherche et
qualité sécurité des soins qui puisse
participer à la nomination de ces de ces
directeurs et qui puisse participer à
leur évaluation
et c'est là que le mot de Coy hiérarchie
arrive et du coup pose problème au
directeur ce que je peux comprendre mais
il s'agit pas d'être dans une coyar
Archie dans tous les sens du terme mais
d'être dans cette
voilà d'avoir si on a cette nomination
partie façon principale domination et à
l'évaluation du coup il nous semble que
c'est une manière de t'obliger quelque
part un peu ces directions
fonctionnelles à partager l'information
de manière voilà très très beaucoup plus
fluide qu'aujourd'hui je m'arrête là
peut-être pour le moment parce qu'il y a
après le sujet du service et d'autres
sujets je pense qu'il viendront docteur
Pinet on va aller dans cet ordre là
merci madame la Présidente bonjour
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
merci de nous donner la parole donc je
suis David Funès je suis vice-président
de la Conférence des Présidents et de
CMG des centres hospitaliers donc
j'excuse Thierry Godot notre président
qui n'a pas pu se libérer pour cette
audition et simplement signaler que
notre conférence représente une grande
diversité d'établissements puisque nous
allons des deux centres hospitaliers
régionaux jusqu'aux hôpitaux de
proximité donc nous couvrons une grande
hétérogénéité d'organisation ce qui peut
ce qui peut amener parfois des visions
un peu différentes et notamment dans
dans le l'objectivation que l'on a du
sujet rappelez que le sujet de la
médicalisation de la gouvernance est un
point de préoccupation très ancien de
notre conférence puisque par exemple
depuis nous avions mené déjà une enquête
en 2018 qui avait dans les résultats
avaient été présentés à Agnès Buzin qui
avait conduit à lancer des réflexions
autour de concertation sur cette
gouvernance hospitalière de la déjouer
et puis qu'il y avait préfiguré la
mission Clarisse qui a été engagée en
2020 et auquel j'ai d'ailleurs participé
c'en est suivi un certain nombre de
textes réglementaires et de circulaire
dont nous partageons les objectifs
puisque le consensus qui était né de
cette mission et de la déclinaison
réglementaire nous faisait sens parce
que d'une part elle nous semblait
faciliter la mise en oeuvre sur le
terrain d'un certain nombre d'objectifs
en réponse aux attentes des
professionnels de terrain et notamment
les équipes médico-soignantes dans les
services avec
comme coeur de cette réforme l'idée que
la mise en oeuvre d'un projet de
gouvernance et de management de
participatif qui a été inscrit dans la
loi dans la loi riste était le peut-être
le meilleur moyen pour amener les
communautés médicales et hospitalières
en lien avec leur direction de d'engager
une réflexion interne pour voir quel
était le meilleur organisations possible
pour répondre aux enjeux des attentes
des équipes de terrain en termes de
délégation de gestion en termes de
reconnaissance des équipes
médicaux-soignantes et puis de redonner
du sens aussi collectif au service avec
en parallèle l'idée de décliner des
engagements respectifs du directeur et
du président de sa mai au sein d'une
charte de gouvernance qui puisse
préciser et donner de la lisibilité à ce
management en binôme qui existe déjà
dans nos établissements et comme l'a dit
le professeur Salomon qui fonctionne
plutôt bien dans la grande majorité des
cas même si parfois en fait ce
fonctionnement binôme manque de
lisibilité au plus près du terrain avec
parfois des
difficultés pour les équipes à
appréhender finalement les circuits
décisionnels au sein d'un établissement
qui en fonction de sa taille peut
paraître plus ou moins difficile d'où
aussi la question de la taille
d'établissement et du lien qui plus ou
moins direct qui peut s'organiser entre
la alternance et les équipes donc dans
ce cadre de cette charte donc il y avait
un objectif de confier des moyens au
président de ces meubles pour pouvoir
pour qu'ils puissent assumer ces
nouvelles responsabilités également
confiées par la loi dans un lien
équilibré avec le directeur mais au-delà
de la personne du président de ces meufs
c'était un représentant de la communauté
médicale qui devait s'assurer que la
communauté médicale et soignante était
bien associée à l'ensemble des
réflexions internes sur la stratégie de
l'établissement qu'elle porte sur la
stratégie médicale en allant jusqu'au
sujet financier également puisque les
CME donnent désormais un avis également
sur les états prévisionnels de recettes
et des dépenses et de ces pommes dans le
cas des nouvelles réglementations
l'ensemble de cette dynamique positive
qui s'est instauré au tour de ces textes
évidemment étaient impactés par la crise
que les hôpitaux connaissent
actuellement donc je vais passer sur la
crise sanitaire covid mais qui a très
vite enchaîné sur une crise des
ressources humaines médicales qui ont
très fortement en tension nos
établissements et dans le cadre de cette
mise en tension au regard des besoins de
santé de la population qui pour un
certain nombre pris beaucoup de retard
je vais signalé la dette hospitalière
qui évoque la Fédération spière de
France régulièrement mais finalement les
professionnels de santé ont du mal à se
retrouver actuellement dans l'hôpital
public tel qu'il le connaissait
précédemment puisqu'ils ont pour un
certain nombre l'impression que
l'hôpital s'oriente principalement vers
des soins non programmés Audrey triman
des activités d'innovation d'expertise
de recours qui font toute l'excellence
de l'hôpital public dans son
organisation interne au sein des CHU des
ch mais également à l'organisme au sein
de l'organisation
territoriale et c'est dans ce cadre là
où la CME le président demeu et le
directeur ont un rôle majeur à jouer
pour redonner du sens travailler et la
cohésion des collectifs évitez les
parpiments et le harcèlement des équipes
et des services mais aussi travailler
sur tous les leviers d'attractivité et
de fidélisation
et d'ailleurs dans toutes les enquêtes
que l'on a pu mener on voit bien que la
participation des équipes aux prises de
décision au plus près du terrain dans le
cas d'une subsidiarité affirmée est un
élément d'attractivité majeur pour
redonner du sens pour améliorer l'envie
de s'impliquer dans un collectif
hospitalier en réponse à des besoins de
santé et c'est là où l'annonce du
président de la République lors de ces
bureaux en début d'année nous a un petit
peu
interpellé au regard de cette notion de
Tandem médical et administratif puisque
nous avions le sentiment que les textes
qui ont été pris en 2021 et 22 tracer
une voix plutôt positive pour l'ensemble
de nos corporations avec un engagement
de l'ensemble des gouvernances
hospitalières autour du consensus qui
avait été trouvé néanmoins ça amené un
élément
factuel aussi qui nous avait amené à
faire un diagnostic qui était que
finalement le changement n'arrivait pas
sur le terrain alors certes il y avait
les contraintes de ressources humaines
certes il y avait toutes les contraintes
que j'ai citées mais nous avons souhaité
objectiver se ressenti qui émergeait
très régulièrement de nos conférences
régionales et nationales et c'est dans
ce cadre là où nous avons mené deux
enquêtes donc nous pourrons évidemment
vous communiquer les résultats si vous
le souhaitez l'une auprès des prisesme
et de CMG qui a recueilli 328 réponses
donc de représentants plus de 100 GT en
France sur les 700 membres de la
conférence et une auprès des praticiens
hospitaliers qui a recueilli presque
6300 réponses pour essayer d'objectiver
leurs attentes les difficultés et puis
questionner aussi les hypothèses que la
mission Claris by devait ramener je ne
vais pas rentrer dans le détail de tous
les résultats mais simplement signaler
que finalement le ressenti que nous
avions au sein de la conférence était
partagé par le terrain avec finalement
des regrets sur le fait que parmi toutes
des objectifs affichés par les textes
finalement la reconnaissance du service
le renforcement du binôme chef de
service cadre la déconcentration des
décisions l'implication des équipes la
délégation de gestion ne se déployer que
dans 10 à 20% des établissements malgré
tout ce qui était inscrit dans la loi et
dans les textes
la fonction de président de ces modes ne
s'était pas améliorée en 2018
84% des présidents cité cette fonction
comme non attractive alors il y a un
petit mieux puisqu'on est à 76% en 2023
mais on voit bien que les choses peinent
à se mettre en oeuvre les chartes de
gouvernance ne sont signés que dans 30 à
40% des cas les projets de gouvernance
et de management participatif qui était
le cœur n'ont été engagés en termes de
réflexion que dans 50% des
établissements et tout ce qui concerne
les codécisions entre les directeurs et
président de CME se met en place dans
80% des cas quand c'est une obligation
réglementaire mais dès lors que ça n'est
qu'une recommandation pour la visibilité
Inter du binôme nous tombons à 20 à 30%
voire à 10% lorsqu'il s'agit de cosiner
des documents extérieurs sur des
conventions médicales sur des
conventions avec l'université d'où quand
même ce sentiment que le diagnostic posé
par le Président de la République autour
de cette tandem était un élément
important en termes de parole politique
pour affirmer que finalement la vision
que l'on portait en 2021 est un élément
du changement pour sortir du seul patron
à l'hôpital qui malheureusement reste
encore beaucoup culturellement dans les
esprits sur le terrain donc en termes de
proposition et sans peut-être avant de
rentrer dans les débats
les deux questionnaires prouvent que les
attentes et comme le disait professeur
allemand sont autour d'un binôme
confortés entre un directeur nommé et un
président de CME élu mais à présent
dememe avec peut-être plus de
responsabilité et plus de moyens pour
assurer tout ce qu'il
a apporté actuellement et en termes
d'enjeux sur le différents que ce soit
pour la stratégie médicale le pilotage
des coopérations hospitalières dans un
lien ville hôpital renforcé avec
une demande par exemple de
représentation aussi officielle du
président summer à l'extérieur de
l'hôpital pour qu'ils puissent être
reconnu en tant que tel par les agences
régionales de santé dans les liens
qu'ils peuvent amener mais aussi par les
collectivités
une des propositions que l'on a
formulées à la mission
clarisbaï était peut-être pour donner
corps à ce tandem de travailler au-delà
de la charte de gouvernance sur une
feuille de route stratégique préparée
par le directeur présente CME présenté
devant le conseil de surveillance qui
engage très clairement ce binôme devant
la représentation hospitalière qui est
désormais
élargi au sein du conseil et en
intégrant notamment les élus dans le
dernier représentation pour s'engager et
présenter de manière périodique une
évaluation des engagements que cette
gouvernance médico-administrative prend
envers ses équipes mais envers également
la population qui le prend en charge et
puis peut-être le dernier point pour pas
rentrer dans le détail sur évidemment
les besoins de formation qui pourraient
conduire aussi à des parcours de
formation managériale tout au long de la
vie pour un certain nombre de praticiens
ce que l'on peut connaître par exemple
dans les hôpitaux d'instruction des
armées qui préparent un certain nombre
de haut potentiels médicaux à la prise
de responsabilité pour ensuite prendre
peut-être des directions d'établissement
ou des directions d'administration
puisqu'on a quelques exemples mais nous
avons bien en tête que à partir du
moment où un médecin sera nommé
directeur il sera directeur et donc il
travaillera en binôme avec un président
de CME et puis peut-être dernier point
peut-être en termes de d'image on croit
beaucoup aussi à l'impulsion politique
alors il y a eu la parole du président
de la République il y aura les
arbitrages qui vont être menés au suite
à la remise du rapport mais peut-être
qu'il y aurait besoin de quelques
évolutions réglementaires pour donner de
la lisibilité à ce duo par exemple une
coprésidence du Directoire qui était un
élément symbolique interne à
l'établissement mais qui pourrait
permettre peut-être de d'améliorer la
visibilité autour de d'une instance de
concertation médico-administrative qui
réunit désormais à majorité en majorité
des représentants médicaux et des
représentants soignants
merci beaucoup monsieur
sur la touche la grosse touche
mesdames messieurs et sénateurs
à rappeler peut-être les éléments de
contexte de
de cette réflexion finalement
deuxièmement à donner quelques éléments
sur la grille de lecture que nous
faisons du sujet et puis troisièmement
appeler les propositions qu'on peut
formuler alors sur le contexte a déjà
été dit le contexte post covid des
systèmes de santé en France et à
l'étranger mais l'accent sur d'autres
sujets que la gouvernance touche
d'accord je pense mais enfin c'est quand
même important de de le dire
alors et de la même façon la crise
sanitaire qu'on a traversé qui a vu 85%
des patients covid être accueillis à
l'hôpital public il faut quand même le
rappeler
à montrer je trouve enfin n'a pas n'a
pas révélé une fragilité de l'hôpital
public bien au contraire on a bien vu et
compris en réalisant des comparaisons
internationales que l'hôpital public a
tenu en France et non seulement il a
tenu mais il a fait preuve d'une
capacité d'adaptation d'in activités on
est tous en mémoire la première vague
les manques d'équipement de protection
et manque de masques de choses donc au
contraire il y a eu une extraordinaire
créativité dans ce contexte on ne peut
pas dire que la gouvernance des hôpitaux
publics est révélée une
fébrilité ou même des divisions
l'état-major n'a été au rendez-vous si
je puis dire de de cette crise inédite
sans précédent etc quand même important
de le noter et puis c'est ce que je
disais tout à l'heure le contexte
aujourd'hui en post covid il est marqué
par par plusieurs choses d'abord un
l'évolution de la relation au travail et
le fait que nos métiers qui sont prolons
les plus contraints de la société
française en travaillant 7 jours sur 7
la nuit etc sont moins attractifs et
donc on a vécu en particulier en 2022
c'est un énorme problème contraction de
l'offre un poste vacant fermeture de lit
contraction de l'offre
des aspects de santé publique qui sont
liés
et puis on sait on va pas c'est pas le
sujet du jour que l'hôpital public au
fond il est victime d'une crise du
système de santé dans sa globalité il a
amené à faire un métier qui n'est plus
le sien bref je reviens pas là-dessus et
enfin pour pour couronner le tout on est
aujourd'hui confronté à des chocs
exogènes qui renvoient à la situation
nationale avec des coûts énergétiques
fantastiques une inflation qui est ce
qu'elle est et donc un modèle qui est
totalement déstabilisé qui vit une
déstabilisation qui n'a pas de précédent
et c'est vrai que dans ce contexte
il nous semble que le les réflexions sur
ce sujet ne doivent pas ajouter des
problèmes à des problèmes par ailleurs
qui existent et qui sont très lourds
c'est pas le moment pour nous
de se réunir et pas de se diviser sur
des points qui ne sont pas décisifs et
puis enfin sur le sur le contexte ça a
été dit il y a eu un travail très
approfondie
minutieux récent assez consensuel sur
l'évolution de la gouvernance le rapport
Clarisse si textes travail récent et il
nous semble qu'il faut voilà il faut
donner le laisser le temps à se corpus
pour qui se déploie quitte à corrigé
telle ou tel aspect pour que ce soit
plus efficace premier point deuxième
point si on essaie de réfléchir à
néanmoins à ce sujet
en prenant un peu de hauteur et il nous
semble qu'il faut probablement le saisir
par la logique de compétences dans un
univers qui reste quand même assez
marqué parce que c'est son histoire par
des tuyaux d'orgue et au fond on a le
choix entre de logique la logique
historique de l'hôpital
c'est une logique de quatre familles
professionnelles
ce médecin soignant administratif
technique ces familles historiquement
sont très cloisonnées elles ont
d'ailleurs généré des lieux des
instances de concertation étanche
elles ont généré des lieux de réflexion
différents le comité de direction d'un
côté ou
les médecins ne sont pas présents le
bureau de la CME de l'autre ou le plus
souvent les directeurs ne sont pas
présents et voilà je crois que c'est
peut-être cela qu'il faut interroger je
suis pas sûr que ça passe par la loi on
y reviendra sans doute mais on voit bien
que si on reste dans cette logique de
famille professionnelle que je ne
qualifie pas de corporatrice je
laisserai chacun tirer le fil
en fait on est dans une logique où on
essentialise la fonction de direction
pour justifier des monopoles on va se
dire les choses telles qu'elles sont et
donc parce qu'on a fait le hesp qu'on en
est sorti à une vingtaine d'années on
est forcément légitime dans tous les cas
jusqu'à la fin des temps pour diriger
les établissements et l'autre le l'autre
côté de la pièce mais qui renvoie même
raisonnement finalement parce qu'on est
entré un docteur on serait légitime dans
tous les cas pour diriger un
établissement mais ça c'est une
essentialisation c'est quand même
quelque chose d'un peu schématique
qui nous semble une vision peu mature en
fait du management de toute institution
on est probablement la dernière
institution à obéir à cette logique
cloisonnée et corporatif qui est une
histoire mais qui n'est pas pourquoi
d'ailleurs elle n'est pas suffisante et
aujourd'hui et je pense d'ailleurs que
ça se passe pas comme ça sur le terrain
sur le terrain on a beaucoup
d'innovations de croisement et Dieu
merci et parce que le management moderne
il nous apprend l'inverse il nous
apprend à mêler les profils à la fois
pour éviter de s'enfermer dans des
raisonnements rassurants mais simpliste
toujours un peu plus et puis
deuxièmement pour arriver à faire
émerger des idées nouvelles or en fait
on vit une époque où la capacité à faire
émerger des idées nouvelles et
déterminante pour notre capacité à
survivre et à faire avancer nos
structures c'est ça aussi l'époque donc
ça ça nécessite le brasser au fond
les profils les réflexions dès l'origine
de façon à éviter les biais de
raisonnement alors du coup ça nous amène
à une deuxième logique qui selon nous et
celle évidemment qu'il faut faire
prévaloir qui est la logique de
compétence et et l'efficacité
aujourd'hui est fondée sur la pluralité
de profil repose aussi sur la pluralité
de profil alors dans cette logique de
compétence
dirigée un établissement est un métier
ça a été dit d'ailleurs le soir la
famille la formation d'origine ce métier
il a des attendus ce métier il s'apprend
en effet si on pense des formations
adaptées c'est quelque chose qui peut
tout à fait s'apprendre il y a des
parcours qu'il faut adosser à ces
formations pour que ce soit progressif
on va se retrouver donc équipement pas
possible du jour au lendemain
puisse et il y a des gens qui ont le
potentiel donc et d'ailleurs si on va un
peu plus loin cette fonction le chef
d'établissement elle implique en fait de
dépasser sa formation d'origine ça
légitimité d'origine celle qu'on avait
au tout début de notre parcours
professionnel pour en acquérir une autre
qui est celle de dirigeants d'être de
protecteur des grands enjeux à moyen
terme de l'institution et puis d'avoir
une capacité à emmener de leadership qui
permettent d'emmener
majorité ou une majorité minorité
suffisante du collectif dans des
institutions qui sont évidemment très
complexes alors si on retient cette
logique compétence et pluralité de
profil nous nous aboutissons à des
composition qui sont un peu les
suivantes je vais très vite les balayer
pour m'arrêter un en effet ce travail de
très grande qualité rapport Clarisse et
texte qui en découle il faut maintenant
vraiment l'appliquer de façon exhaustive
c'est il est assez récent mais il faut y
travailler il y a le tuer les décharges
d'activité
qui est important il est vrai que ce
sujet il est un peu différent suivant la
taille des hôpitaux dans les plus petits
établissements c'est un peu plus
compliqué c'est sans doute il y a la
question des moyens mais à la
disposition des présidents de CME et
c'est un sujet qu'il faut également
travailler parce qu'il faut que les gens
et les moyens de pouvoir se décharger de
tel ou tel enfin la fonction clinique en
fait pour pour assumer les choses et
puis il y a le tuer de la circulation de
l'information on a bien reçu le message
moi je le partage tout à fait je pense
que voilà il faut que les gens les infos
pour pouvoir se prononcer il nous semble
nous c'est une divergence que nous avons
avec la conférence des 30e de Ch qu'en
termes de prérogative nous ne pouvons
pas aller plus loin sur la décision
pourquoi pas de manière dogmatique mais
parce que quand on examine les textes
moi je me suis livré à ce travail
exhaustif en fait sur le champ médical
la codécision est totale donc on voit
bien que si on va plus loin on va
rentrer dans des aspects budgétaires des
aspects de plan d'investissement et on
va basculer dans une logique de diarrhée
en fait et il nous semble que cette
logique de Die dans les temps qu'on va
devoir vivre où il va tout de même
falloir par contre quelques décisions
parfois un peu difficiles parce que les
moyens ne sont pas extensibles à
l'infini il faut pas que on installe une
situation potentiellement de blocage à
la tête de nos établissements ils ont
pas besoin de ça ils ont suivi le
système santé il me semble avoir
suffisamment de problèmes par ailleurs
en France et à l'étranger pour s'en
rajouter un de plus bon
on pourra en parler deuxième proposition
c'est en effet la constitution d'un
vivier pour élargir les profils de
recrutement et donc un vivier pour les
pour nommer des médecins qui le
souhaiteraient qu'il y en aura le pot
logiciel à la tête des établissements
dans notre esprit d'ailleurs c'est
élargissement de le profil n'est pas
réduit au médecin le sujet évidemment
principal et celui-là mais nous sommes
favorables à une ouverture aux
administrateurs de l'État d'ailleurs
c'est ce sont des choses qui se sont
régulièrement produites et qui ont
apporté des choses importantes on pourra
y revenir
ouverture au profil d'ingénieur le monde
hospitalier est un monde complexe on
gagnerait à avoir des gens qui sont
spécialisés dans les organisations quand
même et puis au directeur des soins on a
des coordonnateurs des soins qui sont
pour qui sont pour certains remarquables
et quand on fait des comparaisons
internationales on voit que parfois ils
sont amenés à exercer ce type de
responsabilité alors ça veut dire
constituer un vivier après il y a les
modalités sans doute que la mission by
Clarisse vous en a parlé soit de
remonter de nom à partir des
établissements supports de ght par
exemple et on a des noms il y a des gens
qui en profil
ou encore procéder par rappel à
manifestation d'intérêt enfin avec une
condition que l'on pose c'est l'absence
de nomination sur place là il nous
semble que parce que l'être humain est
ce qu'il est nul ni échappe quand on a
vécu 15 20 ans au même endroit on a des
liens d'amitié et dynamity avec des
ondes de gens surtout quand on a exercé
des responsabilités et ça faut faire mon
panier logique de clan voilà il faut se
garder ça troisièmement alors
c'est un point sur lequel on a une
nuance avec
particulier la conférence des présentes
CM2 CHU mais c'est une nuance parce que
c'est un point qu'il faut travailler
on doit pouvoir
se comprendre là-dessus si on comprend
bien les problématiques respectives
c'est que nous sommes favorables à une
médicalisation de l'équipe de direction
à une ouverture soit sur des fonctions
qui seraient en lien avec le médical les
affaires médicales la recherche la
qualité soit sur des fonctions qui ne
sont pas directement en lien avec le
médical la gestion de projet les
services numériques enfin des aspects de
ce type pour et ça c'est important parce
que sur l'hybridation qui nous semble
être le sujet clé de l'hôpital ça c'est
important c'est dès l'origine avoir ce
regard médical qui nous dit vous faites
fausse route vous avez sous-estimé
l'attente d'une équipe qui va être
complètement démotivée si ce projet ne
voit pas le jour et c'est vrai que quand
on est à la tête d'un Sion qui ont
plusieurs milliers d'agents voilà non
j'ai 13000 agents en fait on n'a pas le
temps de passer une heure sur chaque
projet on gère 35 nations gère 35
projets vous n'avez pas le temps de
faire ça et donc quand on récupère le
dossier s'il n'y a pas eu cette hybr
complète et notamment médicale dès
l'origine on a des biais dans le
décryptage des sujets leur priorisation
et ce type d'aspect formation ça a été
dit tout ça ça implique une formation à
la fois entrer dans l'équipe nomméchelle
d'établissement il faut la prévoir elle
est possible dans notre esprit elle ne
doit pas faire obstacle à la diversité à
la plus réalise la diversification ne
pas oublier le dos le doyen et le
vice-président recherche dans les CHU
qui sont des acteurs majeurs et voilà de
prévu par les textes et il faut il faut
bien sûr le réserver une place
importante et enfin conforter la place
des soignantes nous le corps de la
transition est représente quand même 50%
du 80 de l’hôpital il joue un rôle très
important nous nous serions favorables à
ce qu'ils deviennent vice-président du
directoire voilà je vous remercie
pour terminer Monsieur St-Hubert
voilà là ça marche très bien Madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs merci
de nous avoir invité donc à porter notre
point de vue en tout cas vous vous
éclairez salut je suis très heureux de
d'être là et particulièrement retrouver
le sénateur René Paul Savary avec qui
voilà dans le cadre de mon parcours dans
le grand test et dans l'Ouest
ce matin voilà
de voilà d'avoir travaillé effectivement
nous savons en tant que voilà
hospitalier la place que vous sénateur
sénatrice vous occupez les
préoccupations que vous avez au sujet
donc de nos établissements donc c'est
tout à fait dans un cadre effectivement
de
voir vous éclairer que nous conférences
nationales des directeurs de centre
hospitalier comme l'a dit docteur Pinet
il y a une grande diversité voilà il y a
des établissements de petite taille mais
il y a aussi des établissements qui ont
rôle important au niveau du territoire
vous verrez que la notion de territoire
pèse énormément dans nos propos
alors dans un premier temps il faut
comprendre que il faut prendre en compte
la complexité hospitalière et les
contraintes qui pèsent sur notre système
de santé ça a été dit sa capacité à
répondre aux enjeux de soins curatifs et
au défi de la promotion de la santé
certes autour de la table ronde nous
pouvons avoir des échanges des des
débats parfois des divergences mais nous
poursuivons les mêmes objectifs
faire en sorte que les principes de
notre système de santé l'égalité la
qualité la sécurité la proximité et qui
font de notre engagement professionnel
collectif dans le service public
hospitalier soit garanti
toujours de nos objectifs nous
partageons aussi les mêmes valeurs et
sont celles de nos équipes quel travail
dans les secteurs de soins
médicaux techniques
administratif et logistique
cet aliment fort sans doute doit sans
doute être mieux appréhendé par les
pouvoirs publics qui doivent porter des
démarches favorisant cette concorde
entre les acteurs hospitaliers toute
évolution du droit qui contribuerait à
nourrir
des fonctionnements qui restent encore
trop marqués il est vrai par un
fonctionnement en silo tout intention
qui n'assurerait pas la promotion
d'approche transversale et plus riche
professionnelle
constituerez des erreurs à l'inverse
nous pouvons aller plus loin ce qui a
été dit par exemple sur l'identification
d'un vivier de mes seins mais pas
seulement des médecins d'ailleurs prêt à
prendre davantage de responsabilités
des tronçons de formation commun entre
directeur pcme l'élargissement du champ
des codes décisions possibles par
exemple des médecins médiateurs mais
aussi la consécration de temps dédiée
aux fonctions de pcme et de pcmg
n'oublions jamais cette dimension
territoriale que nous devons développer
et pour redynamiser le service échelon
essentiel dans la vie de nos
établissements pourquoi ne pas aller
vers un projet médico-soignant présenté
par un binôme chef de service et cadre
de soins par exemple au pôle et au
directeur et au président de CM la
gouvernance hospitalière est appelé à
évoluer comme dans tous les secteurs
professionnels mais comme la rappeler le
ministre de la Santé il ne faut pas
remettre en question ce qui fonctionne
mais obligé à ce que cela fonctionne
partout par contre quel que soit sa
composition la gouvernance doit avant
tout évoluer dans un cadre clair et
sécurisant évoluer dans un cadre clair
et sécurisant et madame la Présidente
nous n'y sommes pas
plusieurs exemples
qui tousse contrarient la gouvernance
hospitalière notamment les directeurs et
les PCM
premièrement un cadre sécurisant c'est
un cadre qui n'est pas en constante
mouvance
quel grand secteur se réinterroge tous
les j'écris 18 mois mais je vais dire 12
mois
sur sa gouvernance et modifie ses
processus décisionnels quel secteur
connaît de tels changements sans donner
le temps à l'appropriation des acteurs
aucun
et ces changements ne sont pas faits en
partant d'enseignement tirés traitant
tous les aspects des problèmes par
exemple sociologiques sur les
conséquences des évolutions sur le
rapport au travail
c'est une question essentielle
même l'impact du rapport Clarisse de
2021 n'a pas été évaluée
certes des enquêtes sont faites par les
conférences par les uns et les autres
je le reconnais mais il nous faut sortir
du prisme partial et parfois trompeur de
l'opinion des opinions nous sommes
suffisamment dotés d'universités
d'organismes de recherche qui pourrait
faire des analyses fines qui dépassent
la seule vision des acteurs directs
deuxième point pour le cadre sécurisant
c'est aussi éviter les actes et des
décisions contradictoires je pense à
l'inadéquation entre les objectifs fixés
par la nation traduit pas par exemple
par le manuel de la chaîne et les moyens
consentis à travers la détermination de
l'ONDAM cela place les acteurs notamment
les directeurs et les présidents de CME
mais aussi les directeurs des soins dans
une tension qui se répercute à tous les
échelons de l'hôpital
regardons l'investissement hospitalier
oui des milliards qui ont été
consentis mais aujourd'hui nous avons
des hôpitaux dans un état de vétusté et
comme on a dit que le copermo on en
faisait plus mais je vous assure que on
est toujours dedans
un cadre sécurisant pour la gouvernance
hospitalière le troisième point c'est
aussi avoir une vision politique une
vision politique cohérente un exemple
jamais nous n'avons été autant sollicité
pour développer une vision territoriale
de l'offre de soins par exemple
récemment pour accompagner la mise en
oeuvre des mesures sur l'intérim médical
mais concrètement mais concrètement
quels sont les outils les leviers
opérationnels et en termes de
gouvernance qui sont mis à notre
disposition pour faire vivre le
territoire
vous sénateurs vous avez au niveau de la
gouvernance territoriale
pratiquement aucun nous le savons tous
les ght y compris leur mode de
gouvernance sont restés au milieu du gué
avançons sur la médicalisation des
territoires
nommé un médecin au sein des équipes de
direction pour aider dans ce domaine
pour être une piste mais à la condition
qu'il s'articule parfaitement avec le
pcmg du ght dont le rôle doit être
confirmé et qui doit être associé au
choix du médecin territorial par exemple
une des propositions du rapport Clarisse
baille il faudrait également que les
doyens participent par exemple une fois
par an à toutes les CMG de leur
territoire
il y a un vrai sujet d'irrigation à
partir de nos chutes de l'ensemble du
territoire
l'implication des élus dont chacun
convient pourtant qu'elle doit être
renforcée doit être davantage en termes
de gouvernance territoriale
s'il vous plaît ne restez pas dans vos
établissements prenez en compte des
problématiques de l'ensemble du
territoire
un cadre sécurisant pour la gouvernance
hospitalière c'est aussi le respect de
la parole de l'État nous ne pouvons pas
comprendre qu'alors que l'État s'est
engagé à ce que la revalorisation des
Hospitaliers via le Ségur que les
directeurs demandés depuis des années et
les présidents CME ne soient pas
intégralement compensés pour les
établissements alors que beaucoup de ch
et vous le savez c'est sont déjà en
situation financière d'extrême fragilité
et des ch qui sont extrêmement
fragilisés financièrement par les
déficits des budgets médico-sociaux
40% des déficits hospitaliers de ch sont
dues à l'insuffisance de financement du
secteur médico-social
un dernier point un cadre sécurisant
c'est reconnaître les atouts et
compétences des hospitaliers et de sa
gouvernance vous le savez jamais
l'hôpital et ça a été dit
si souvent pourtant si souvent et
facilement dénigré n'a été aussi
résilient inventif par exemple
s'agissant de l'ingénierie des métiers
de la santé en plaçant la confiance au
cœur des évolutions jamais il n'a autant
promu la concertation et la
participation des ces personnels à la
définition de leur quotidien il se
malgré toutes les difficultés jamais il
n'a autant essayé d'honorer sa
responsabilité populationnelle malgré
les difficultés rencontrées par la
médecine Neville et le fait que les
contraintes hospitalières par exemple la
permanence des soins n'a pas
d'équivalent conduisant un sentiment
légitime d'injustice
alors pour conclure nous portons
quelques messages simples
si l'hôpital a une culture marquée par
la hiérarchie des médecins incarnés pas
dans un temps si lointain dans les
mandarins ou les patrons termes qui a pu
également désigner les directeurs alors
que ceux-ci ne se sont jamais reconnus
dans cette position
désormais les Hospitaliers aspirent à
participer plus directement à la vie de
leur établissement c'est une évolution
sociétale cette aspiration est exprimée
donc par tous les professionnels le défi
consiste à ce que la gouvernance
hospitalière reconnaisse à leur juste
place et valeurs les différentes
cultures et Métiers demain la
constitution d'un vivier de médecins ne
sera pas suffisante et nous devons
avancer dans de nombreux domaines par
exemple en instaurant désormais un
co-portage de la politique qualité
et pertinence de soins ainsi que
l'accueil des usagers par la CME et la
sieste
comme directeur
nous portons
animaux au quotidien les relations et
logiques entre les trois forces que
constitue
l'hôpital
celui des professionnels médicaux
soignants et les autres professionnels
la première force celui des élus
tous les élus du territoire celui de
l'État nous avons un système de santé
dont la politique nationale est définie
par l'État il y a donc trois pouvoirs
trois forces que nous devons gérer dans
nos structures aussi il nous semble
capital que l'indispensable équilibre
entre ces trois forces et ces trois
pouvoirs
professionnels élus état passe par une
reconnaissance de chacun à sa juste
place
au sein de la gouvernance hospitalière
il ne s'agit pas simplement de changer
des étiquettes des uns et des autres il
s'agit de parler des responsabilités que
nous devons
exercer en responsabilité il s'agit de
développer la logique coopérative
dans nos organisations
donc je ne parlerai pas de directeur je
parlerai de la fonction de dirigeant de
l'hôpital
elle doit s'habiller sur une solide
formation doit être porteur donc de
cette approche à la fois complète et
équilibrée je vous remercie merci
beaucoup nous avons des questions moi
sur le vous allez réagir peut-être les
uns et les autres par rapport aux propos
quand vous parlez de trois parts moi je
partage ça après est-ce que les parts
doivent être égales c'est autre chose
mais
élu étant
personnel des établissements
jusqu'où pour vous va la codécision
principe de codécision parce que je vais
redire ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure et
qu'on m'a dit qu'un tandem les deux
pédalem il y en avait qu'un qui
conduisaient donc un moment jusqu'où va
cette décision c'est toujours très
difficile à un moment il faut il faut
que la décision soit prise mais je vais
passer la parole à Corinne Imbert
Bernard joumi Annick jacquemais Nadia
sur le groupe merci bien ma présidente
merci messieurs pour vos interventions
une première question est-ce que le
Président de la République a fait le bon
diagnostic
voilà
il est pas médecin et voilà mais bon je
voudrais qu'on revienne un peu plus
parce que je vous ai entendu mais sur
l'audition précédente ça nous a été dit
il y a plein de d'endroits plein
d'hôpitaux ou la gouvernance se passe
bien
donc la question qui vient derrière
est-ce que des décisions qui pourraient
être prises après le rapport qui sera
présenté au président de la République
au gouvernement on va pas risquer de
déstabiliser ce qui marche bien et si on
veut pas toucher parce que ça nous a été
dit on toucherait pas ce qui marche
alors est-ce qu'on va pas avoir une
gouvernance à plusieurs modèles
est-ce qu'il faut est-ce qu'il est
pertinent d'imaginer justement un modèle
de gouvernance commun à l'ensemble des
établissements ou au contraire est-ce
qu'il est souhaitable de distinguer les
établissements selon leur taille leur
mission et leur catégories et puis
peut-être pour revenir ça a été évoqué
justement sur la dernière intervention
de Monsieur Saint-Hubert la place des
doyen est-ce que dans le cas particulier
des centres hospitaliers universitaires
quelle place pourrait le être accordée
dans la gouvernance au-delà de la
tournée des CMG dans la gouvernance
aux côtés du tandem ou d'un trinôme qui
pourrait être envisagé et puis une
dernière question pour laisser la place
à mes collègues faut-il et si oui
comment intégrer dans les évolutions de
gouvernance la représentation des
personnels paramédicaux et le rôle des
commissions des soins infirmiers de
rééducation et médico-technique voilà je
n'arrêterai la je vous remercie
continuez les questions et alors Bernard
Chaumier
mais auparavant je voulais réagir aux
propos de Monsieur Saint-Hubert parce
que vous nous avez en fait interpellé
assez de façon assez directe c'est juste
je trouve vous avez dit notamment voilà
est-ce que les objectifs fixés par la
nation qu'elles sont-ils et sont-ils
respectés vous connaissez comme nous
comment est voté la loi de financement
la sécurité sociale c'est-à-dire elle
n'est à aucun moment précédé au
Parlement d'un temps de débat sur les
objectifs de la nation en termes de en
l'occurrence pour vous de politique de
santé et pour ce qui est de l'onde
amospitalier de ce qu'on attend de
l'hôpital et c'est pas faute de le de
l'avoir réclamé alors il y a une petite
amélioration dans le process on doit
dire depuis la loi organique proposée
par Thomas Meunier qui est qu'au moins
les députés découvrent pas les documents
trois jours avant et le délai c'est un
peu allongé mais on n'a pas on devrait
avoir maintenant
en juin juillet au Parlement le
gouvernement devrait nous présenter un
document stratégique voilà les la
politique de santé les objectifs de
santé de la nation parce qu'il est là et
puis on devra en débattre et à partir de
là construire le budget moi je suis
incapable de vous dire ce que sont les
objectifs fixés par la nation on s'est à
peu près ce que veut l'exécutif et
encore nous on s'exprime de façon
parcellaire donc puisque voilà on n'a
pas de ce process on a au moment du
PLFSS des discussions mais vous savez
que la marge des parlementaires est très
limitée on ne peut pas aggraver la
charge publique donc c'est c'est très
compliqué et bon donc vous posez une
vraie question
et et le fait qu'elle ne soit pas
débattue dans de bonnes conditions
Parlement faute justement la façon dont
les choix sont opérés et la lisibilité
de ses choix pour les acteurs du système
parce que vous avez appelé à une
stabilité je pense je lis derrière la
lisibilité en fait des choix voilà donc
je voulais vous dire ça moi j'avais
trois questions une vous n'avez pas
parlé de la commission des soins
infirmiers alors certes ok pcme
directeur très bien bon enfin il y a
quand même d'autres personnels soignants
à l'hôpital
deuxièmement la question de la
différenciation un hôpital de proximité
la gouvernance en fait si elle est pas
ouverte sur le territoire sur le
médico-social avec toutes ces
interactions c'est quand même
problématique donc quels sont vos
réflexions en la matière et
troisièmement le conseil de surveillance
est-ce que vous attendez est-ce que vous
estimez qu'une évolution
composition prérogative je vous laisse
répondre du conseil de surveillance est
un élément d'évolution de la gouvernance
et puis vous pourrez répondre Annick
merci madame la Présidente merci
messieurs pour vos informations vous
exposez moi j'aurai trois questions
est-ce que vous pensez que la
modification de la gouvernance
hospitalière si elle si elle se fait
passe par une réduction du personnel
administratif dans les hôpitaux dans
l'hôpital français d'après mes chiffres
se sont 405 600 personnes qui se dédient
à des tâches autre que médical soit 54%
de plus qu'en Allemagne
dont la population et pourtant près de
25% supérieurs à celle de la France que
pensez-vous
d'externaliser une partie des fonctions
techniques et administratives est-ce que
ça permettrait de faire appel aux mêmes
services à moindre coût et puis de ce
fait là peut-être de dégager des
ressources pour mieux payer le personnel
soignant la deuxième question que je
voudrais vous poser c'est concernant
l'investissement qui permet d'accélérer
le virage numérique dans la gestion
managériale bureaucratique mais aussi au
niveau des dossiers médicaux
avec ma collègue Marie-Pierre Richer
nous sommes membres de la DDF la
délégation des droits aux femmes et nous
faisons en ce moment des auditions pour
un rapport sur femme et santé au travail
et au cours de nos auditions on a
entendu plusieurs fois des personnels
soignants que ça soit des infirmières
des auxiliaires etc et qui nous disait
le désintérêt finalement qu'amène le
numérique dans leur métier parce que
elle ne se trouve plus du tout
auprès du malade nous disait qu'elles
étaient souvent dans les couloirs à
rentrer des données sur les ordinateurs
et que ça perdait finalement leur sens
alors justement professeur Salomon je
sais que vous êtes assez sensible vous
l'avez dit au bien-être au travail alors
que pensez-vous justement de ce virage
numérique qui est sûrement inéluctable
mais ce qui a pas un manque de formation
ou une prise en compte aussi finalement
de ces métiers
dans la proximité par rapport aux
malades et la troisième question que je
voudrais vous poser
certains hôpitaux ont déjà adopté des
recommandations formulées par d'anciens
gouvernements et je pense notamment à
l'hôpital de Valenciennes présidente
vous en avez parlé tout à l'heure
on a vu que les dirigeants ont pris une
décision courageuse qui était de
responsabiliser les soignants en leur
accordant une autonomie managériale
l'autre décision
c'est que les médecins et les
pharmaciens ont accepté cette
responsabilité
voilà donc l'hôpital de Valenciennes a
poussé la délégation attribuée au chef
de pôle en leur accordant le droit de
signature qui permet de passer commande
d'embaucher et jusqu'à 90% du budget de
l'hôpital
par ailleurs les chefs de pôle médecin
sont secondés par des cadres supérieurs
et des cadres administratifs formant un
trinôme en charge du pilotage de chaque
pôle donc chaque pôle a un budget des
ressources et des objectifs de règles et
de gestion et on voit que dans cet
hôpital alors je sais pas si ça peut
être si c'est déjà dupliqué si ça peut
être dupliqué ailleurs mais le personnel
médical et soignant et embauché à
hauteur de 80 personnes par an depuis 7
ans et il y a un bon dialogue social qui
s'est effectué le taux d'absentéisme et
c'est surtout ça qui est important et
faible il est inférieur à 8% bien en de
ça de ce qu'on trouve au niveau national
et puis là dans cet hôpital le personnel
administratif ne représente plus que 5 %
des salariés contre 30% en moyenne dans
les hôpitaux français alors que
pensez-vous de ce modèle que pensez-vous
et pourquoi est-ce qu'on le retrouve pas
plus dans les autres hôpitaux merci sur
le logo oui merci madame la Présidente
alors moi comme mes collègues avec
beaucoup de questions on fait pas de
question j'ai plutôt une remarque
professeure vous avez commencé en disant
c'est pas le plus urgent aujourd'hui
alors bon c'est à la marge mais de façon
un peu taquine j'avais envie de vous
demander comment vous auriez priorisé
les autres urgences pour qu'on travaille
efficacement et non mais dans les
travaux qu'on a amené récemment sur la
situation de de l'hôpital en France moi
j'avais entendu au contraire quand même
souvent ce sujet sortir des réflexions
autour de la gouvernance alors je
comprends ce que vous disiez monsieur
Saint-Hubert faut peut-être pas trop se
laisser emporter par ce ressenti mais
c'est quand même un problème qui est
sorti de façon prioritaire et
Monsieur pardon monsieur essaie vous
dire que oui c'est sur l'hôpital public
a tenu pendant la crise covid mais on a
quand même entendu des soignants qui
nous disaient que si il a tenu c'est pas
pendant cette période particulière la
pression administrative quelque part
c'est quand même relâché en été pendant
le quoiqu'il en coûte et les soignants
ont fait sortir que pendant cette
période ils ont pu travailler d'une
façon différente voilà je vous remercie
interpellé tout à l'heure quelle
question simplement on dit souvent que
dans l'hôpital c'est une structurelle et
que parfois il y a plus de barreurs que
le rameur
est-ce que vous vous pensez pas que
entre les 5 % affichés à Valenciennes ce
dont je doute à mon avis au point de vue
administratif et les 30 à 35 %
d'administratifs qui doivent être la
moyenne des hôpitaux nettement plus
importantes que dans les autres pays il
faut simplement rééquilibrer tout ça
parce que partout il y a des gens de
bonnes volonté qui soit barreur ou
rameur simplement il faut quand même qui
est un dirigeant
un dirigeant qui remet tout le monde
dans le bon sens me semble-t-il mais un
dirigeant effectivement
alors qui commence en prendre dans le
même ordre oui professeur Salomon là
vous avez donc c'est vrai j'ai dit qu'il
y avait d'autres priorités donc je peux
les évoquer on les a évoqué moi alors
après il nous faudrait deux trois heures
devant nous parce que c'est du coup je
pensais qu'on parlait surtout de la
gouvernance mais oui elle est évident et
Francis Saint-Hubert l'a dit Bernard a
repris il faut qu'on ait les moyens de
de
qui correspondent aux besoins là pour la
faire très courte on parle beaucoup de
prévention j'étais ce matin dans un
service où on traite les accidents
vasculaires cérébraux moyenne européenne
plus 30% d'ici 2035 plus 100% 80 100 %
d'ici 2050 et on sait qu'on peut
prévenir beaucoup de ces accidents
vasculaires cérébraux à condition qu'on
s'en donne les moyens donc oui il est
grand urgent aujourd'hui de mettre en
route une grande une vraie politique
ambitieuse de prévention on y est pas du
tout donc moi je peux vous parler de la
santé scolaire je peux vous parler de
voilà plein de choses qui sont
l'attractivité dans les métiers du soin
c'est une vraie voilà c'est aujourd'hui
ce qui nous empêche le plus donc il y a
une évolution sociétale et ça a été dit
aussi le rapport au travail etc la
contrainte est beaucoup moins acceptée
qu'avant et pour autant à l'hôpital on a
besoin de travailler 7 jours sur 7 24
heures sur 24 donc il faut mieux
rémunérer cette contrainte il faut
travailler sur les conditions de travail
et là je me tourne vers Bernard jaumier
il y a aussi pour les soignants la
charge de travail qui compte beaucoup et
donc je vous remercie d'avoir voté très
majoritairement la proposition de loi
sur les ratios qui était qui a peut-être
été mal compris c'était aussi un sujet
de discussion mais ça se fait comme pour
le budget dans une perspective plus
réelle il faut qu'on ait un plan plus
réel on le fait pour l'armée on devrait
le faire pour la santé un plan
pluriannuel sur tous ces sujets là pour
remettre en selle l'hôpital le rendre à
nouveau attractif
avoir une régulation entre le public et
le privé entre la ville et l'hôpital
ouvrir enfin et on a beaucoup parlé moi
je suis très attaché à cette idée du CHU
an sur le territoire et donc ouvrir les
portes du CHU est irriguer le territoire
que le CHU porte aussi j'ai parlé de la
prévention sur la santé publique porte
ce score Robert durée souhaitait à la
fin de sa vie et qui n'a pas été fait
c'était voilà 50 ans après on a on n'a
pas avancé lui espérait que les gens à
qui s'adressaient le prennent personne
ne l'a pris en France donc il faut que
le CHU porte ça c'est à dire la
formation la recherche dans le domaine
de la santé des soins primes en soins
primaire et donc je pense qu'il y a des
choses à faire créer du lien entre la
médecine de ville et l'hôpital ça c'est
des choses qui sont urgentes à faire
aujourd'hui donc voilà donc il y a
tellement de sujets et sur le numérique
pour vous répondre c'est un sujet que
qui m'est cher que je connais un peu
aussi parce que j'ai été
j'étais dans la direction scientifique
de l'iachu imagine à Necker je n'ai
pédiatre à Necker et donc j'ai on m'a
demandé de travailler sur ce sujet là au
moment où on a construit conçu le le
imagine puis en même temps il y avait
des centres de référence une maladie
rare ce début des années 2000 et donc on
réfléchissait à faire des bases de
données on avait compris que c'était un
truc important donc c'est important pour
le soin et donc c'est ce que vous disiez
le l'outil informatique est un outil
dont on ne peut pas se passer mais
clairement une réflexion tout de suite
sur l'investissement à nouveau dans le
domaine de l'informatique du numérique
nous n'investissons pas assez à
l'hôpital on investit pas assez pour
entretenir les hôpitaux on investissent
pas et je pense qu'il faut le voir dans
de la même manière qu'on doit entretenir
ou construire un bâtiment il faut qu'on
investisse plus dans le numérique pour
avoir des outils qui soient qui nous ont
parce qu'on est souvent empêché parce
que ça marche pas bien ça marche pas
bien ça rame l'imprimante qui pas
connecté le machin j'entends ça tous les
jours tous les jours c'est je peux vous
dire que c'est un des choses qui vient
en premier alors s'il vous plaît on a
tellement on a tellement besoin de
soignants dans les hôpitaux au moins
qu'on les embête pas avec ces trucs là
ça c'est sûr et donc il faut un peu plus
d'investissement l'investissement je
crois de mémoire sur le numérique dans
les hôpitaux français
entre 1 et 2% et plutôt plus près de 1
je crois que de 2 si vous allez en
Amérique du Nord c'est plutôt à 4 ou 5
ou entre 4 et 5% dans certains pays
d'Europe du Nord c'est aussi entre 4 et
5% donc il faut juste il y a pas que ça
il y a pas qu'une question de
d'investissement mais ça vous permet
aussi de payer de bien payer il y a
peut-être aussi une évolution des
statuts de la fonction publique pour
puisse à recruter des informaticiens de
haut niveau pour pouvoir aussi bien
faire fonctionner donc etc donc sur le
numérique oui vous avez raison si on
s'embête avec ça sur juste un mot sur le
personnel administratif parce que
j'entends aussi souvent ça je pense
qu'il y a mon avis moi je fais un
diagnostic un peu différent je pense que
on a je pense pas qu'on est trop
d'administratifs je pense qu'on les
occupe à des à des tâches qui pourraient
être évitées et je pense que les que les
soignants ont aussi des tâches
administratives et c'est ce qu'on
appelle le glissement de tâches et donc
je pense qu'il y a parce qu'on compte
dans le personnel administratif ça
dépend comment on compte mais si on
compte les secrétaires médicales par
exemple souvent on les compte dans le
administratifs souvent on manque
aujourd'hui même si le numérique permet
aujourd'hui de peut-être de de changer
ce métier là on a moi je vois les
internes et les externes dans mon
service et c'est vrai dans les autres
services passent leur journée devant
l'écran et ils sont plus dans la chambre
du patient donc il y a un problème il y
a un vrai problème et en plus il sort
des comptes-rendus d'hospitalisation qui
qui sont moins à mes yeux pas très
satisfaisant en qualité c'est important
d'avoir une compte-rendu une lettre de
sortie de bonne qualité pour donner
l'information aux correspondants etc
donc il y a un vrai sujet autour de
l'informatique il y a aussi tout aussi
tout le sujet de la cybersécurité là on
est là je je
ne me dis pas plus mais vous voyez qu'il
y a un vrai sujet il y a aussi dans le
domaine de la recherche l'utilisation du
numérique qui nous permettra là c'est
vraiment un autre porte maintenant de
faire de travail en réseau et je reviens
sur le territoire sur la possibilité de
croiser les données ceux qui sont
générés à l'hôpital celles qui sont
générés en ville et de mettre tout ça
ensemble ça nous permettra d'accélérer
beaucoup mieux faire de la recherche
dans les domaines très pointus du CHU
mais aussi dans des domaines et je
reviens sur le la recherche en soit
primaire aussi sur ces domaines-là qui
doivent être si on veut améliorer le
taux de diminuer le taux d'accident
vasculaire cérébraux il faut qu'on soit
aussi capable de comprendre quels sont
les déterminants de ces maladies-là
c'est-à-dire là où les gens vivent ce
qu'ils mangent comment ils travaillent
quels sont les tous ces déterminants et
donc ça ça s'analyse il faut faire des
études épidémiologiques de bon niveau et
ça on sait pas le faire aujourd'hui donc
voilà si on voulait je le bosse très
rapidement donc là j'ai pas parlé de
gouvernance mais mais c'est évidemment
des sujets qui me paraît meilleur juste
peut-être un mot pour pas être plus long
enfin deux mots sur les soignants et les
doyens j'en ai pas parlé mais Philippe
tu as un diamant évidemment
alors sur les doyens c'est c'est à
l'évidence ils doivent être associés à
la gouvernance du CHU sinon ça n'a pas
de sens c'est un sujet un peu compliqué
parce que on a il y a il y a eu des
communications récemment de France
université et de temps en temps on se
s'interroge un tout petit peu sur sur la
place que les uns et les autres veulent
prendre et c'est vrai que la gouvernance
hospitalo universitaire n'est pas si
simple que ça on a deux ministères de
tutelle donc on a une structure qui est
aujourd'hui Robert Debré avait bien
compris qu'il fallait mettre un seul
endroit les gens qui faisaient de la
clinique et ceux qui faisaient de la
recherche et qu'il fallait une pluralité
des des profils là on vient aussi
introduire aussi plus de sciences
humaines si on veut travailler sur la
prévention donc tout ça l'université
peut doit la porter ça c'est une
évidence mais il faut bien et moi je
suis très je pense qu'on partage ça la
recherche clinique ce sont les elle est
au plus proche du patient et donc il
faut que c'est là c'est vraiment là que
les choses doivent se passer et donc les
doyens doivent être associés à la
gouvernance de manière très étroite et
sur les soignants
sur les soignants à l'évidence oui on a
alors j'avais dit le service j'avais
laissé pour après mais le service il
faut enfin ce qui marche bien au niveau
du service c'est quand l'équipe de soins
au sens large médecin paramédicaux
travaillent ensemble font des conseils
de sa vie prennent du temps pour se
parler de l'organisation du travail de
l'organisation du soin et que le binôme
chef de service cadre de soins cadre de
proximité
marche bien en bonne confiance donc ça
c'est vraiment l'échelle la plus
importante et au niveau de la direction
de l'hôpital oui la Commission des soins
elle existe c'est pas exactement le
symétrie de la commission médicale parce
que je rappelle que le directeur de la
commission des soins n'est pas élu
contrairement aux présidents de la
commission médicale donc ça fait quand
même une différence et c'est pour cette
donc ça c'est première remarque après je
pense qu'il faut contre la PC la
commission médicale et la Commission des
soins il est plus effectivement
d'échanges je pense qu'il faut qu'on ait
sur beaucoup de sujets qu'on puisse
favoriser moi à chaque fois que j'ai pu
avoir des échanges avec des cadres
paramédicaux travailler avec eux ça a
toujours été très réfléchissant donc il
faut qu'on le fasse plus donc voilà et
plus d'autonomie au service ça c'est un
truc c'est c'est évident on n'a pas fait
quand on dit on fait pas le bilan il y a
des réformes qui viennent les unes après
les autres il y en a une c'était HPST
c'était quand même il y a plus de
maintenant 13 ou 14 ans on n'a pas fait
le bilan des pôles et donc c'est vrai
que il faut aussi qu'on qu'on redonne au
service beaucoup plus de de marge de
manœuvre d'autonomie et je suis pas sûr
que ce soit uniquement de dire on va
déléguer de la gestion et toute la
gestion administrative telle que le
modèle de Valenciennes je sais pas moi
je m'interroge un tout petit peu mais en
tout cas que ceux qui font le travail le
soin dans les services soit plus entendu
quand ils disent des choses et qu'on
écoute et notamment les médecins alors
les médecins ils poussent un coup de
gueule ils sont ils arrivent au moins on
m'a dit quand est-ce que j'ai pris le
service on m'a dit tu vas voir si tu
veux être entendu il faut que tu tapes
du point sur la table mais il faut que
tu tapes fortes parfois il faut taper
fort et c'est un peu vrai il faut passer
des coups de fil etc et bon c'est pas le
meilleur manière de faire je pense mais
du côté para médical on a une hiérarchie
qui est très très pyramidale très
pesante et les cadres de proximité ont
du mal par contre à dire ça c'est vrai
et donc il faut que le binôme mais
beaucoup du côté paramédical puisse être
entendus au moment où il exprime les
besoins dans le service et après il y a
un dialogue de gestion après tout ne
peut pas être accordé bien entendu il y
a des contraintes mais au moins qu'ils
soient entendues de manière très
attentive par la direction
beaucoup de questions je vais essayer de
synthétiser sur le sujet
des coécisions est-ce qu'il faut aller
plus loin ou pas et est-ce qu'on risque
pas de déstabiliser ce qui marche je
crois qu'on regarde et enquêtes qu'on a
pu mener enfin si on part sur la voie
d'un renforcement d'un pcme en binôme
avec un directeur nommé je raconte peu
qu'améliorer les choses là où on
pourrait déstabiliser c'est
éventuellement des arbitrages différents
types CLCC ou autre qui n'ont pas été
abordés puisque ça ne fait pas partie
entre guillemets de la vision que l'on a
de l'évolution de la gouvernance dans
nos établissements néanmoins si on veut
que ce binôme la conférence préfère le
terme de binôme que de Tandem parce que
comme vous l'avez dit on préfère la
binôme l'un à côté de l'autre qui va
dans le même sens que que l'un derrière
l'autre mais fonctionne et encore au
regard des quelques retours d'expérience
de ces dernières années on a le centre
que si ce n'est pas réglementaire les
choses ne se font pas on avait beaucoup
misé en 2021 sur des recommandations de
bonnes pratiques le guide Clarisse avait
présenté les bonnes pratiques
managériales identifiées dans un certain
nombre d'établissement pour essayer de
guider des déclinaisons dans un certain
de d'établissement et forcer de
constater que si les consignatures ne
sont pas réglementaires finalement elles
peine à se déployer et c'est vrai qu'il
y a de plus en plus un écart alors on
l'avait objectivé en 2020 entre les
équipes de terrain on l'avait appelé ça
la rupture de faisceau et le top
management qui réuni les directions et
praticiens qui participent à la Gwen
d'établissements mais c'est vrai qu'il y
a un écart aussi entre les annonces
politiques de plus en plus et enfin la
réalité sur le terrain c'est à dire que
le Ségur de la Santé met en avant cette
délégation au plus près des services
repositionner service et puis finalement
quelques années après on peine encore et
on cherche la bonne manière d'avancer
sur le sujet donc avoir un objectif plus
réglementaires et peut-être une
contrainte qui pèse sur les gouvernances
malheureusement c'est peut-être un des
leviers dont on doit pouvoir utiliser
pour pouvoir avancer sur ces sur ces
sujets
ce qui m'amène également à amener une
nuance sur la place du directeur médical
au sein d'une équipe de direction ou
d'une équipe d'un directeur médical
territorial au sein au sein d'un
territoire je pense qu'il faut faire
attention par rapport enfin vis-à-vis de
ce modèle à ne pas déstabiliser
justement le rôle que l'on souhaite
donner au président dememe ou au
président de CMG donc toute cette
dynamique qui a été engagée maintenant
depuis plusieurs années pour engager un
collectif pour essayer de porter une
stratégie médicale qui est partagée et
travailler avec les directions et de ne
pas penser que ce directeur médical dans
l'équipe de direction bah fera le tandem
avec le directeur et là on risque
vraiment de casser l'ensemble de cette
dynamique d'où un peu notre divergence
sur le sujet comme l'évoquer monsieur et
le saillir tout à l'heure sur les
différents modèles de gouvernance alors
c'est vrai que les pas abordé dans notre
plateforme de proposition c'est vrai que
on met à part les hôpitaux de proximité
vous l'avez dit il y a le modèle de
l'hôpital de proximité est une
labellisation qui peut être un si
géographique d'un établissement ou un
établissement à part entière qui a une
gouvernance propre qui
repose sur le plan médical sur deux
peut-être difficultés un faible nombre
de praticiens souvent dans ces
établissements et une interaction très
forte que l'on souhaite avec les CPTs
avec les représentants de ville etc et
je crois que les textes législatifs et
réglementaires prévoyaient déjà cette
gouvernance un particulière donc
peut-être que c'est l'occasion au regard
de ces évolutions de l'affirmer et de le
réfléchir différemment d'un modèle qui
serait peut-être uniforme sur l'ensemble
des autres centres hospitalier et puis
je n'aborderai pas à les CHU mais
évidemment sur la place du Doyen avait
été également objectivé comme un élément
important sur le sujet de la place des
soignants alors c'est vrai que c'est un
petit peu passé à l'AS dans la
présentation des textes mais finalement
la loi risque
repositionnée à ses fortement la
commission de soins infirmiers de
rééducation et médico-technique dans
cette gouvernance avec des prérogatifs
propres on n'a pas interrogé dans nos
questionnaires la place que cette cire
devait prendre théoriquement après la
loi mais je pense je pense
qu'elle ça assez peu évolué mais
peut-être que c'est l'occasion aussi
comme on souhaite le refaire sur les
autres volets de la mise en application
de ces textes de lui redonner toute sa
place il existe également un droit
d'option pour essayer de réunir les CME
Lexium dans les établissements qui n'a
pas été
repris par les équipes peut-être du fait
aussi que la réflexion sur le projet de
gouvernance et le management de
participatif n'a pas beaucoup avancé
dans nos établissements mais c'était une
option qui était intéressante et puis il
y avait d'autres options notamment au
niveau territorial avec une
sous-commission de la commission
médicale de groupement et partager avec
l'accident de territoire donc il y a
déjà un certain nombre de leviers pour
avancer sur ce sujet mais je crois que
l'enjeu au-delà de
s'en parler de la place du père médical
dans la au directeur mais l'enjeu est
vraiment de redonner des marges de
manœuvre au service je crois que sur le
plan
médico-soignant c'est le meilleur c'est
le meilleur niveau de travail à l'heure
actuelle même si il faut encore qu'on
affine l'articulation entre Cesme
et puis nouvelle composition du
directeur médico-soignante sur le sujet
des personnels administratifs dans les
établissements je crois que l'exemple de
Valenciennes était comment dire une
cible attendue aussi des textes c'est à
dire d'aller vers un niveau de
délégation de gestion affirmé au niveau
des pôles jusqu'au service
malheureusement les choses peinent
encore à avancer c'est peut-être un
moyen aussi pour redistribuer
différemment l'ensemble de des
personnels administratifs et de
faciliter les circuits courts de
décision en réponse aux irritants du
quotidien
mais c'est vrai qu'il faut faire
attention aux chiffres parfois macro qui
sont présentés si demain on prône des
assistants médicaux pour gagner du temps
médical ils vont peut-être être encore
comptabilisés comme du personnel
administratif en fonction des
classifications donc il faut vraiment
rentrer dans le détail et je n'ai pas le
sentiment pour travailler de manière
conjointe avec beaucoup de direction
d'établissements ou d'équipe de
direction que ce soit un poste qui soit
réellement pléthorique et qui soit
pointé du doigt par les équipes
soignantes on cherche vraiment à garder
un collectif et une cohésion chacun à sa
place avec ses moyens il y a peut-être
parfois des atypies mais je pense pas
qu'il faut en faire une généralité sur
la place du conseil de surveillance
vous avez abordé tout à l'heure
en termes de composition enfin ce qui
est intéressant pour le conseil de
surveillance et qui réunit finalement
l'ensemble des acteurs avec des
représentants de la CME de la cire de
des représentants syndicaux des élus des
collectivités des usagers donc ça je
pense que c'est un bon niveau aussi pour
être parti prenant dans le sublimer
l'évaluation d'un certain nombre de
d'organisation interne d'où la
proposition que l'on avait formulée d'un
contrat de gouvernance ou d'une feuille
de route stratégique qui subissent être
présentée au conseil de surveillance par
le directeur et le présent dememe pour
affirmer ce binôme et pour ensuite les
engager à titre personnel dans la prise
en charge de leurs responsabilité
vis-à-vis de l'ensemble de l'hôpital et
c'est peut-être un élément nouveau que
l'on pourrait porter enfin sur le virage
numérique professeur Salamon l'a très
bien décrit donc je vais pas rentrer
dans le détail mais je partage la
problématique des investissements les
problématiques d'ergonomie qui sont pas
forcément toujours
penser par des é diteurs qui ont
maintenant des capitalisations
européennes ou internationales et puis
peut-être
amener aussi cette réflexion en termes
de qualité de vie au travail dans nos
établissements sur le bon usage du
numérique pour ne pas non plus aller
dans l'hyper traçabilité quand ce n'est
pas nécessaire mais c'est vrai que c'est
un biais que l'on connaît tous
les sujets évoqués sur veux-tu sur votre
point sur la codécision
j'ai dit ce que j'en pensais on peut pas
être on peut pas décider de choses dont
on n'est pas responsable donc
voilà le principe de base c'est que
l'unicité de décision du chef
d'établissement indépendamment de la
question de savoir qui doit être chez
l'établissement c'est un autre sujet
mais le sujet de l'unité décision du
dirigeant de l'hôpital et indissociable
et en tout cas pour corollaire fort ça
responsabilité qui est à la fois
administrative pénale et financière
devant la cour du speed budgétaire
financière moi je dis souvent qu'en 22
ans de chez Fred établissement puis ça
fait 22 ans que je suis établissement
j'ai été mis en examen ou témoin assisté
16 ans
je vous donne cet exemple c'est bon
c'est une réalité
il y a pas que voilà sur il y a un autre
question qui est un autre point qui est
très intéressant qui est pas une fois en
fait
ce serait le sujet de notre audition
c'est vraiment quelles sont les
priorités de l'hôpital et je trouve que
c'est ce qu'on se disait c'est à dire
que
il y a comme ça quelques hochets qui ont
le don de nous fixer de nous mobiliser
et dont on n'est pas absolument sûr que
ce soit le cœur du sujet
on voit bien que
le le
sujet de l'hôpital c'est que chemin
faisant progressivement sur 20-25 ans si
on se remémore moment on est rentré dans
nos carrières les moments on était
enfant encore plus mais l'hôpital
n'avait pas le même métier l'hôpital
n'avait pas le même métier donc sur
20-25 ans on voit bien que la première
ligne de soins sous le poids du
vieillissement sous le poids de la
pathologie chronique sous le poids d'une
démographie médicale qui n'a pas été
assez anticipée en fait elle a plié et
que et que on se retrouve nous de face
on peut l'appeler activité non
programmée on peut la position avec une
activité qui n'est plus une activité
d'hôpital et ça je crois que c'est un
problème majeur d'ailleurs c'est un
cercle vicieux parce que moi plus notre
métier s'étend plus les pouvoirs publics
nous demandent des gains de productivité
pour arriver à financer enfin c'est un
cercle vicieux sans fin et c'est quand
même assez préoccupant parce que en
parallèle le progrès médical et c'est
une bonne nouvelle s'accélère
c'est-à-dire que nous sommes tous autant
les uns que les autres dans des
établissements qui délivrent des
traitements à 500.000 euros par personne
2 millions d'euros par par patient et
c'est une bonne chose voilà c'est
l'université de notre système mais en
parallèle avec une paupérisation assez
générale de notre système de son bâti de
son informatique
d'absolument on gère ce paradoxe et là
où je trouve qu'on sait enfermé dans un
piège autant les uns que les autres
d'ailleurs on y a peut-être participé
c'est qu'on est arrivé à persuader les
Hospitaliers que allait culpabiliser
comme si d'ailleurs les médecins
n'étaient que des dépensiers et genre
c'est au courant quand même si on
arrivait pas à essayer de faire les
choses telles qu'elles doivent l'être et
comme si les directeurs ne pensaient à
leur compte non et donc on est arrivé à
nous culpabiliser à nous enfermer dans
une guerre intestinale alors que notre
problème c'est le système de santé quel
est le métier de l'hôpital ça je trouve
que c'est c'est important en tout cas
que nous on emprunte conscience sur la
place du soin bon moi j'en ai je rejoins
tout à fait je pense que
attention à ce qu'on soit pas dans un
débat un peu bilatéral où on oublie la
moitié du personnel de l'hôpital donc ça
il y a une place très importante à le
reconnaître c'est pour ça qu'on est
favorable à une vice-présidence du
directoire pour les les directeurs des
soins
le doyen on en a beaucoup parlé je crois
qu'on est tous d'accord il y a eu une
sorte de maladresse qui a consistait à
ce que les domaines de cossignent pas
les nominations de chef de service il
faut revenir dessus ça ne pose aucun
problème
l'université moi m'a envoyé toute une
note sur le sujet à tout le monde vous
êtes de recevoir aussi je les avais reçu
en entretien bon ils ont pas un sujet il
faut et on est prêt on est tous très
attachés à la place du Doyen voilà dans
l'ambiance des CHU sur le personnel
administratif alors moi je dis
attention danger
là on est dans un piège populiste c'est
alors c'est très facile quand on voit
mais oui oui 54% de plus par rapport à
la main c'est faux la Fédération
hospitaire de France il faut qu'on vous
communique l'étude à
mener les études répétées là-dessus
effectivement les personnes
administratives les plus abondantes que
nous ayons en plus grand nombre de
hôpitaux c'est les secrétaires médicales
juste le titre mais en fait quand vous
retraités vous sortez les personnels
discrétaires de nos effectifs on est à 5
ou 6% de personnel administratives dans
les établissement et d'ailleurs certains
d'entre vous ont de grandes
collectivités territoriales près de chez
vous
comparer la taille de nos institutions
et leur niveau d'administration avec la
taille de certaines grandes
collectivités je rentre je rentre pas
dans le détail mais je suis pas sûr je
suis pas sûr que le final soit sur
administré donc attention attention aux
agrégats
un peu simpliste sur le conseil de
surveillance sur le conseil de
surveillance
je pense qu'on peut faire des choses je
pense HPST a été trop loin dans un sens
restrictif tout de même donc il y a des
choses qu'on peut faire sur la qualité
sur des domaines sur lequel le Conseil
d'assurance ne délibère pas aujourd'hui
ne décide pas en revanche on aura
l'occasion de l'exprimer à Frédéric
valthou demain d'ailleurs
je pense que sur le la délibération sur
le PRD le budget
on se rajoute un problème politique
puisque je pense que si on va vers ça
les grandes métropoles françaises si
vous faites la cartographie et vous
regardez un petit peu ne voteront pas le
repère des là c'est moi j'avais compris
que les réformes étaient faites pour
nous aider on avait des soucis et qu'il
fallait nous aider j'ai pas compris
qu'il s'agissait de tout nous rajouter
des problèmes enfin il dit que les
fédérations sont favorables
on va en discuter avec lui on va en
discuter avec nous et puis je termine
sur nous c'est notre point de vue
prenons prenons les grandes métropoles
françaises à commencer par Paris Lyon
Marseille
on passe vite enfin bon mais ça peut
être un choix
les fédérations n'ont pas n'ont pas
forcément vu le problème parce que bon
il y a collectivité que l'activité il y
a des aspects de taille de collectivité
[Musique]
et donc le vote de la région sera pas
nécessairement le vote de la ville de
Paris sera pas nécessairement le vote du
représentant des Hauts-de-Seine etc
voilà donc il peut y aura voilà c'est
pas la fin je pense que il faut rester
un niveau plus principal pour l'occasion
en l'occurrence
si vous avez des 15 plus grandes
métropoles françaises qui ne votent pas
le perdait parce qu'elles sont
interpellées par les personnes et parce
qu'en fait il y a un problème
[Musique]
les élus sont interpellés par les
personnels et s'accordent pour dire que
il y a pas assez de moyens pour la santé
moi je c'est pas je vous dis juste qu'il
y a un sujet
moi je vous dis que si les 15
principales métropoles qui ont des
couleurs politiques différentes à
arriver au même vote c'est qu'il y a un
problème
sur le Conseil d'options
qui a été dit c'est à dire que
là aussi il y a un espèce de paradoxe
c'est-à-dire que le numérique fait
beaucoup de progrès d'ailleurs il permet
de suivre beaucoup de monde à domicile
il y a pas de modèle économique mais
enfin c'est quand même une piste
intéressante il faudrait en faire
quelque chose et c'est aujourd'hui en
effet un irritant majeur qui revient des
services
parce que les outils sont mauvais
attendez parce que les outils sont pas à
la hauteur et ils sont pas à la hauteur
parce qu'on n'est pas assez d'argent
dedans
parce que quand on traverse l'Atlantique
on se rend compte qu'il y a des outils
parfaitement performants seulement nous
n'avons plus de marché en France parce
qu'on est on vise trop donc à un moment
donné on a éteint le marché ce qui veut
dire peut-être que le prochain plan
d'investissement à l'hôpital il faudra
le faire sur le numérique moi je pense
qu'il faut vivre avec son époque et les
enjeux Dias et les outils qui sont
ouverts sur la ville enfin
sur Valenciennes je rejoins ce qui a été
dit je suis pas sûr que Valenciennes
soit un modèle universel c'est un modèle
à regarder attentivement et ça peut être
une source d'inspiration il faut voir au
cas par cas en revanche je rejoins ce
qui a été dit sur les services et sur
les je pense qu'on a
un sujet d'épaisseur de nos structures
hospitalières on a des hôpitaux en
France pour ça on a une diversité
d'établissements enfin pour certains qui
font 5 6000 agents dix mille agents
15.000 agents 20 000 agents et donc la
question c'est comment rapprocher la
décision du terrain et là on peut il y a
une réflexion qu'il faut poursuivre
monsieur Saint-Hubert oui beaucoup de
d'éléments qui ont été donnés donc je
vais pas forcément revenir sur chacun
des établissements pour partir quand
même sur le un des derniers propos qui
où vous avez réagi sur les budgets et le
conseil de surveillance
ce que le problème politique soulève mon
collègue il est réel mais pas simplement
dans les grandes métropoles ça peut
concerner aussi des établissements de
taille modeste voilà au sujet je pense
qu'il faut effectivement prévoir
les modalités d'arbitrage en particulier
qui existent il faut peut-être les les
améliorer mais nous ce que nous disons
au titre de la conférence c'est que à
partir sa réponse aussi à votre question
est-ce que au niveau de l'ONDAM la façon
dont nous déterminons les moyens que la
nation veut consacrer par rapport aux
objectifs que la nation se donne c'est
une vraie question fondamentale c'est
pas juste voilà alors c'est compliqué
c'est une question compliquée bon là on
parle des indicateurs de santé publique
non c'est c'est pas suffisant c'est pas
quelque chose qui est si évident que ça
donc je pense que la question est bonne
disant mais la réponse va être compliqué
mais cette interrogation ensuite elle se
traduit au niveau de chaque hôpital au
niveau de chaque hôpital nous avons ce
sujet là est-ce que les objectifs
attendus de l'hôpital mais on a des
indicateurs qui peut par exemple las
dans le cadre de la certification nous
avons des obligations donc il suffit on
a une réglementation je vais aller plus
loin sur par exemple la sécurité
incendie vous connaissez bien donc à un
moment donné on peut quand même essayer
de se pencher sérieusement par rapport
aux obligations que nous donnons à nos
établissements je ne sais pas tout à
l'heure on a on s'est comparé avec
l'Allemagne pardon
je trouve que c'est vraiment hasardeux à
un moment donné de sortir des chiffres
des indicateurs sans qu'effectivement on
puisse poser le Pass poser les problèmes
de façon globale
c'est hasardeux c'est dangereux je pense
qu'il faut je suis désolé de le dire
tout à l'heure j'ai parlé de dicte des
opinions les approximations des
impressions via des enquêtes via des
noms ce n'est pas possible de continuer
ainsi deuxième point il existe une vraie
tension en matière de décision qui est
de dire est-ce que je donne la liberté
est-ce que je compte sur les acteurs sur
place qui puisse prendre des décisions
ou comme le disait docteur Pinet tout à
l'heure si ce n'est pas réglementé ce
n'est pas fait c'est à dire qu'en gros
on a un état qui contraint qui
réglemente bonjour à cette vision où il
faut tout réglementer sinon ça marche
pas vous allez avoir beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de travail
donc à un moment donné je dis juste que
bon faisons une pause regardons mais
allons jusqu'au bout c'est pas
simplement parce qu'on réglemente que ça
va marcher vous savez bien qu'en
sociologie
quel que soit les organisations que nous
mettons
pardonnez-moi de prendre cet exemple
c'est avec beaucoup de respect que je
l'ai fait c'est lui qui balaye il a
toujours une marge vous pouvez lui faire
une fiche de poste vous pouvez lui
demander d'écrire tout ce qu'il fait il
aura toujours une marge pour faire ou ne
pas faire voilà et ça c'est valable pour
toutes les organisations donc nous
devons trouver cet équilibre entre
effectivement
réglementé moi j'ai plutôt vous avez
tous entendu parler du notch management
c'est-à-dire que comment un écosystème
comment
l'environnement peut amener à faire
évoluer les comportements des uns et des
autres
c'est là dessus que nous devons investir
c'est sur cette réflexion là voilà et
comment créer le collectif le modèle de
Valenciennes je vais être oui il marche
probablement mais je crois aussi qu'on
le survend en donnant des choses voilà
il y a des très bons commerciaux moi je
dis attention l'hôpital n'est pas un
centre commercial
l'hôpital n'est pas un centre commercial
où chaque boutique fait son profit fait
ses commandes ou ça ne veut pas dire que
nous sommes contre la délégation contre
effectivement il puisse y avoir une
partie mais aujourd'hui
le nombre d'hôpitaux qui sont en déficit
vous voulez qu'on délègue les déficits
au chef de Paul et au chef de service
alors réglons d'abord les problèmes de
la distribution des moyens entre les
nations et les hôpitaux ensuite on se
penchera sur la question comment à
l'intérieur de l'hôpital n'imaginons pas
que les problèmes de fond vont être
résolus avec un peu de cosmétiques en
mettant un peu de code décision en
changeant un peu les étiquettes tout ça
non ce n'est pas possible
concernant juste pour terminer sur les
administratifs pardon voilà une
secrétaire médicale c'est une
administrative ou pas
l'agent qui est accueille quand nous
avons des bornes quand nous avons voilà
pour faire le dossier d'entrée admission
l'agent qui accueille c'est une
administrative ou c'est une soignante
dorer les précisions sur les chiffres
qui ne sont annoncés et bien écoutez
nous sont prêts à discuter
en ce qui concerne donc sur le conseil
du surveillance moi je pense que
les établissements doivent préserver
leurs identités parce que les soignants
ont besoin d'appartenir à un service à
un pôle à un hôpital nous devons
préserver cette identité mais nous
devons absolument les amener vers une
identité territoriale vers des
considérations territoriales aujourd'hui
nous savons qu'il y a des hôpitaux des
services qui ne peuvent pas tenir on ne
peut pas à la fois dire je défends mon
hôpital et ne pas être cohérent dans les
décisions que l'on prend sur les
professionnels et l'installation des
professionnels de santé nous sommes nous
savons que nous sommes au pied du mur
donc quand j'ai dit tout à l'heure que
l'envir un environnement sécurisé c'est
un environnement ou en garantit et qu'il
n'y ait pas de parole contradictoires de
décision contradictoires alors il faut
aller jusqu'au bout
si on doit garder tous les hôpitaux tous
les services il faut le nombre de
professionnels et il faut quelque part
être en capacité oui je suis d'accord
les politiques d'incitation financières
d'installation tout ça ça n'a pas marché
je ne suis pas en train de militer pour
dire qu'il faut obliger l'installation
des praticiens mais peut-être qu'il y a
d'autres voies nous avons un système de
santé qui écloisonné par des métiers il
faut faire très en d'études de 13-15 ans
d'études pour être médecin 3 ans pour
être il fait nous pour être infirmiers
alors il y a les IPA tout ça ce sont des
excellentes choses mais je pense que
nous avons nous devons aller vers des
nouveaux métiers des nouveaux métiers
intermédiaires ou pas c'est pas très
joli mais des métiers ou avec 7-8 ans
d'études de niveau d'ingénieurs on soit
en capacité de faire un certain nombre
de choses que les médecins sont seuls à
faire aujourd'hui
et que d'autres ne peuvent pas donc
vraiment c'est un appel que je vous fais
travaillons rapidement sur ces métiers
intermédiaires à la fois donc la
formation le mode conclusion se trouve
dans la formation notre capacité à
revoir nos appareils nos systèmes de
formation à la fois pour mettre en place
les nouvelles formations aujourd'hui
dans nos systèmes on consacre 2,1% de
nos budgets pour les formations
doublons le pendant un certain temps
dans nos établissements et donnons-nous
les moyens de former les gens et vous
verrez les gens sont heureux et notre et
ne poseront plus les questions
d'étiquette merci notre très très
rapidement très rapidement je partage
complètement le dernier propos de
Francis Saint-Hubert sur la formation
c'est un enjeu majeur que ce soit la
formation des médecins la formation des
paramédicaux on n'a pas assez dans ce
pays penser la formation en fonction des
besoins avec la nouveau de la
prospective sur sur le long terme
qui a vraiment un vrai sujet c'est vrai
que la question des moyens complique
tout mais il y a aussi quand même une
question de confiance
de de des directions envers les les
responsables l'encadrement médical et
paramédical et l'encadrement est un
sujet là aussi majeur
encadrement médical ça en prend pour
nous il faut que les médecins chefs de
service probablement il y en a qui font
très bien donc ils font moins bien donc
il faut qu'on soit aussi plus attentif à
la qualité de ce qu'on dit le management
de la qualité d'animation de l'équipe
c'est très important l'ambiance dans un
service et pareil pour et encore plus
pour les paramédicaux là il y a aussi ce
métier en très peu attractif
actuellement les conditions sont dures
donc il faut aussi vraiment revaloriser
le métier de cadre et lui donner une
manière de le revaloriser aussi c'est le
reconnaître le cadre dans sa capacité à
dire les choses et à être entendu je
pense que ça c'est vraiment je reviens
dessus parce que c'est un point qui me
paraît majeur
merci merci beaucoup à tous les quatre
de cet échange passionnant qui ouvre
plein de pistes de réflexion à
poursuivre et on attend on attend le
fameux rapport
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup